Go
in, go in, you go in first.
Okay, now I'll go in.
That's why you go in first.
That's why.
Remember, if you want me to rob your house make sure you
have a spotlight shining in the sky to call for me all right
guys until we meet again my dear park nights
you're still here all the park nights left already we're
supposed to go to that concert an hour remember
oh my god oh we're gonna be late park nights oh thank god i
know a shortcut it is through this alleyway oh my gosh okay
it's a little bit of a dangerous part of the town but we
gotta make it to the concert guys oh man there's a lot of
these yellow little bird things hanging out here i don't
think i've seen them before guys have you guys seen these
birds before park nights They must be new in town, I swear.
Dragoons for life?
What a weird little name they have.
Are they like some army or something, Bark Knights?
Yeah, what are those things?
Oh my gosh, one has like a Mohawk.
Okay, all right, we can't solve.
The other Bark Knights are waiting for us at the concert.
All right, all right, oh, hey.
Oh, hey.
One of them has a camera, Bark Knight.
What?
Do you little guys want a photo?
Oh, is this a scam, guys?
Guys, you know, like, the scams in New York, guys?
You know, like, where they, like, try to take your picture,
and then you have to, like, pay them, like, $80 per photo?
What's your name?
Dragons?
What a funny name.
You guys don't have anyone to go to, so you hang out here,
right?
Dragons?
That's pretty sad, you know?
my park nights like we have each other so like it's pretty
sad you guys are just loitering here without like anyone to
look after you guys i mean well i hope you dragons find
someone one day instead of loitering this alley it's pretty
dangerous anyway oh okay okay we'll take a photo only if we
don't have to pay you I mean, Spark Nights, you guys think
that's a scam?
I don't know.
Like, do we trust him?
He's yellow.
And he's, like, pretty chonky.
He said the first one is free.
And, like, I don't know.
I don't know.
You think he's gonna scam us?
You think this dragon is gonna scam us, Spark Nights?
Trust?
Whoa.
Whoa!
Do not trust yellow birds.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
All right, all right.
We'll do one photo, sir.
One, only one photo.
All right.
And you promise us you won't charge us?
Fine.
We'll do it.
All right, guys.
Get ready.
Just get ready, guys.
He wants a photo.
All right.
three two one oh okay i was not expecting that but okay all
right let's let's see the photo
are you okay well i mean they got you guys you know you know
at least i guess because like the cameraman is pretty pretty
short well at least you got your photo at least you know but
i feel like i feel like we should get another photo guys uh
this i don't i don't know this the scene is just you know i
don't think i want to keep this one bright nights uh so
let's go you know what sir how about look i think you sort
of you know a photo has to be good for both people both
sides you know like for uh both participants in the photo so
that come on one more photo one more one more photo and and
if it's a good photo i'll pay for it okay no no no no no no
no 80 you fucked up on the photo you got the barth knife but
you only got my shoes come on how is this a good souvenir a
hundred dollars for the second one what are you okay a scam
artist look i'll give you money if you give a good photo but
i'll take another one i'll do another one all right all
right all right are you guys ready all right we're gonna do
another photo guys i'm not i'm not really a fan of that
first photo i feel like obviously like he was not paid he
got you guys look great you guys look great in the photo of
bark knights but like they just got my shoes i mean my shoes
did look pretty sick like i mean i just got them they're
like they were i got at a thrift store uh down the street
and it was pretty cheap and I think it was one of the best
finds I got this year.
But, but this year in 2020, but this year, which I would
like to specify, is 2020.
But I feel like, I feel like we should get another one
where, you know, both of us are in the picture.
And, you know, my face is in the picture too, Dark Knights.
All right, let's do another one.
All right, we're ready, cameraman.
We're ready, Dragon.
all right in three two oh all right okay all right didn't
listen to the countdown again but that's okay that's okay i
think now that barton i think now that um he you know he
took in criticism i'm pretty sure the next photo will be a
lot better all right so let's see let's see the next photo
okay i mean you got at least it's not defeat this time
I mean, yes, Barak Knight, that is my hand.
Why am I so tall?
Why are you so small?
Sorry, above average.
My above average Barak Knights.
All right.
Sir, sir, sir.
I feel like, you know, if anything, this photo.
might be worse than the last one so I feel like we should be
able to grab another photo and no no no no no no no no no no
I'm not paying you for that photo I didn't even count to
three yet how could I have to pay you when you didn't even
wait for me to do the countdown you literally took a picture
at two and then you didn't even take a good picture so all
I'm saying is that I believe we me and the bark night
because bark night you're on my side right all right bark
come out vouch for me we believe that we deserve another
photo um because this is not it you know if you're gonna try
to start a business here a small business owner like you
know you're not doing a great job right now and if you want
me to not review bomb you right now do you know who i am
dude well i'm not really anybody oh i i like i only stream
to like 10 people but i'm gonna i swear i swear i'm i'm
gonna be someone one day and you're gonna regret it anyway
take another photo i demand another photo all right okay all
right okay bark night we we okay bark night we we got
another photo okay
So we gotta make sure, we gotta make sure this time, this
time, um, we're, we're gonna be in frame.
Um, he's gonna actually get a picture of my face this time,
not my hands, uh, not my feet, but like, both of us in
frame.
Are you ready?
Are you ready, Bark Knight?
All right, let's do another count.
Okay, let's do another count.
Three, two, oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
I'm pretty sure after I like we've I've calmly explained to
the this this dragon Uh, that the third photo would be fine
All right, what does the photo look like sir
What the what the fuck is this guy?
You didn't even take a picture of my bark that who the fuck
out when did he crash the photo?
Also, also this is in our appropriate, sir.
This...
Sir, I...
This is very in a...
You're so lucky.
I'm not going to report you right now.
We are late for a concert.
You're very lucky that I won't report you.
But also, where the fuck did this bird came from?
Where's my...
You didn't even include my bark knight.
You didn't even include my little dog.
Where is he?
All right.
At this point, I feel like we deserve like five free photos
at this point.
Anyway.
Got another photo.
Next.
Give me another one.
All right.
Bark knight.
Here.
I'm going to.
I'm going to pick you up this time.
And it'll be.
I'm going to.
I'm gonna pick you up this time, okay?
And then, and then this time, this time, there's no other
yellow bird that's gonna crash this photo, all right, that's
not gonna photo bomb this photo.
So are you ready?
Is this our four photo?
I've lost count, actually, Bark Knights.
Uh, yeah, so I'm gonna pick you up real quick.
All right, here's some little uppies.
All right, how many photos has this been?
I've already lost count.
No, sir, you are not charging us for four photos.
Like, all four of them are unusable.
All right, all right, let's try this again.
This time.
Four times the charm, I believe.
Wait, I didn't even hear the camera click.
Where did you take this photo?
How did you get a photo of my dog?
out wait a minute where did you get this photo where did you
get this photo of my dog he's not even here right now i okay
this is breaking i think i think this is a creep bro i think
also what's that egg doing here you're an egg in my photo
what is he doing here like i think i think it did make me
something wrong with this with this yellow bird i i don't
even know where he got this photo of me and my with my dog
too i mean that's true the egg is pretty dripped up but like
where is his parents where why is he why is he hanging out
why is this child this baby out with with all these yellow
berries where are his parents all right all right all right
I demand all right this time actually take our photo okay
dragon actually we we are like we are late right now to a
very important concert okay we took this shortcut uh
thinking that uh we are gonna make now i am not so sure
because uh because we're here still taking photos but uh i
believe this will be the last photo and if it's a really
really good photo sir um i'll give you a tip okay how about
that dragon i'll give you a tip if you can provide us with
one good photo and then we'll we'll have we have to go like
right away after because i don't want to be late for this
concert guys like you know what we've been you know i've
been looking forward to this concert for a long time guys
you guys know that right because like come on i got like i
dressed up just for this concert you guys come on um so one
more photo and then and then and then we can go all right
and and you can get a really nice tip if you give us a
really good photo sir all right are you ready break nights
are you ready all right we're gonna do another countdown
here we go three two one oh my god oh my god he fucking oh
my god he actually he actually did it okay all right all
right all right what does it look like
this is i guess i guess i guess it's close enough i guess i
well my park nights aren't there but like we got a pretty
cool bird i guess i get i mean he does he does have pretty
cool jacket is that for
um is that versace jacket he has that's i guess that's
pretty sick but my my dragon my dragon is having trouble
taking one photo look i have let me check my watch i have
five minutes left sir and look i believe in you that you can
take one good photo like sir if you take this photo and I am
in frame and my my bark night is also in frame I swear to
God I will make sure I will make sure you make it you know I
know like this is like your dream job and you're trying so
hard to make it in this world this cruel harsh world out
there as a photographer and you know what they say practice
makes perfect and sir look you took five photos and you are
getting better you know you are you you got half of the face
so you you are getting a little better and i believe in you
i believe the last photo the sixth photo which by the way i
had this has to be the photo sir like i i i have to go to
the concert man i i cannot do one more
and if you nail this photo i will make sure not only to pay
for that one photo not the other ones because the other ones
there's no way you're not making me pay for those other
photos but if you take a really good photo i will make sure
to tip you at least 10% that's pretty good you know in this
market in 2020 10% is pretty good especially you working out
here during um especially because like you weren't even
wearing a face mask sir so like I mean me too but like me
too during 2020 but but like that's different I'm
so so sir if you take this photo and it's a good photo i'll
make sure to tip you 10 and also recommend you to all my
friends all all my bark knights too um anyway all right are
you ready bark knights all right we're gonna take one more
photo all right he's in guys he's irresponsible
Book, guys, don't you remember?
We booked this ticket like a year ago.
How was I supposed to know?
I booked this ticket a year ago.
Anyway.
Anyway, guys.
All right.
Are you guys all ready?
Are you ready for the photo?
Bark night?
Don't worry.
I don't think there's any more yellow birds that's gonna
party crash us.
So we'll be fine.
No worry.
As long as you, as long as you're like in frame, we should
be good to go.
Alright, remember, stand to my right, okay?
You should be bigger.
Like, I don't think we already kicked out the other yellow
birds.
I think that was the last one, right?
But there was a long one.
There was, uh, there was an egg.
And there was like a tiny, tiny little bird.
And I think, That's all of them, right?
I'm pretty sure.
I don't think that's all of those yellow birds over there.
All right.
I wonder where their owner is.
I wonder where their parents are, too.
Like, they're just looting here.
I feel like someone's got to, you know, take care of that
problem.
All right.
Are you guys ready?
In three, two, one.
All right.
Let's check out the photo.
Did you get it?
Wait, I think he said...
guys bark nice i think he said i think he got it he's giving
me the thumbs up oh my gosh i knew it see bark nice
threatening people is okay as long as as long as we get what
we want i told you guys life lessons with joki he gave us a
thumbs up let's see how it let's let's look at the photo
Yeah.
Park night?
This giant chicken?
Park night, speak to me.
Are you, sir, get off him.
Sir, please.
Oh my gosh, great.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, where's my glasses?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh, sorry.
I know you're like getting crushed right now, but I dropped
my glasses.
I didn't even realize this.
After all those failed photos, I didn't even realize I
dropped my glasses.
Let me pick my glasses real quick.
Give me a sec.
Oh!
Dragoon, get off him!
Get off this!
Get off my partner right now!
Oh my god!
Get out of here!
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Alright, he's okay.
okay uh bark night squishy gummy ours streamer now we did it
we eliminated the bark night now she's ours like what do you
mean what do you mean ours these are my bark nights don't be
with me forever all right no no no no no you that that photo
is a freebie because you crushed my bark night in fact i
deserve i demand another photo right now i demand another
photo you crushed my bark night so you should give me
another photo you're lucky i won't even sue you you're so
lucky i could sue you right now you crushed you crushed my
bark night you're so lucky you're lucky he's like a squishy
and he has no bones in there you're so lucky and that sword
is just plastic look you know what instead instead of suing
you i'll let you take one you have to take one more photo
for me
i feel like i get to have another photo And then, maybe I
won't sue you.
Alright, is that a deal?
Is that a deal, sir?
And you know what?
Since I feel really...
I feel really humble and nice today, I let your friends join
this photo, too.
I let your little yellow birds, your dragons, or whatever
they're called, join in on the photo.
Is that a deal?
How about that?
I won't sue you.
you and also let your friends be in this photo.
I, you're so lucky.
You're so lucky.
You're so lucky that we have to go to a concert too.
So, so we don't have a time to like, you know, I could have
called the cops, you know, but because we have to go to me
in the bar tonight, I have to go to a concert.
I won't sue you and I won't call the cops.
You just gotta take one more photo for us.
All right, all right, break night.
We're gonna take one last photo before we go to the concert.
All right, don't let them get crushed, okay, this time?
Don't get crushed.
All right, all right, come in.
Come in, dragons.
Come in, all right, yep, yep.
Oh, oh, there you all are.
Okay, all right, that's cool.
There you guys, there you go.
Oh, there's so many of you guys.
All right, all right, are you guys ready for one more photo?
Alright, on a count of three We go Barth Knights forever And
then you take the photo Okay, sir Alright Alright, I'm ready
Are you guys ready, Barth Knights?
And I guess Dragoons, right?
That's your name?
Alright, Dragoons and Barth Knight Are you guys ready?
Alright Ready?
And three Three, two, one, bark next!
Alright, alright, alright, alright, we gotta go now.
Alright, I'll see you guys later, you little freaky yellow
birds.
I hope you guys, uh, I hope you guys find your Oshi one day.
Um, it must suck to just like be in this alleyway day and
night with nothing to do.
But I hope you guys find your Oshi.
Me and my bark next, we gotta go now.
Alright, I'll see you guys later.
Bye-bye!
Bye!
Wow!
Oh my god!
I can't believe we've made it in time, Park Nut!
I can't believe!
I thought we were gonna be late after like, you know, taking
like 20 photos back there.
Um, I don't know if you noticed, but I didn't even pay for
any of the photos.
You did not know.
See it, Park Night?
I can talk my way out of anything.
You didn't even know I didn't pay him for the photos.
And look at that, Park Night.
We got...
We got six free photos now!
As souvenirs!
That's right.
Scammer got scammed.
You didn't know that I'm secretly a thief.
I know it's so stupid oh my god anyway oh I can't believe
we're finally here we weren't even late for the concert I
mean I hope we weren't late because I mean honestly like
that would be pretty fucked if we were late because I don't
know it's obvious bark night but I'm the opening act so that
would have been very awkward uh so i'm glad i'm glad we made
it here in time i really am look at that oh my god there's
more of these yellow birds here too wow there's so many of
them oh my god oh it is feeling a little cold though so let
me oh before before we before i go on the stage let me put
on let me put on my my my shirt back up um oh my god i'm so
nervous though are you nervous right now i mean it's been a
i i think you know i don't really sing we've only uploaded
one cover song back then you know was it the drift away and
embarrassed you know i don't sing like night but i'm very
surprised that you know they asked me to they asked me to do
be in the opening act for this concert and of course i
picked one of my favorite songs and i felt that was super
appropriate um uh to like this i guess oh yeah for you guys
uh for imagine dragons oh my god that's why there's so many
dragons here i know i can't believe it i can't believe uh
the the imagine dragons asked me to be the opening act too
anyway um they asked for like some a punk punk-esque sort of
song and i was like you know what avro levine she's the punk
pop princess um she is the queen of punk pop so and the
queen of punk honestly and i felt like i felt like this was
perfect a perfect song um to celebrate um um to celebrate
our time together you know anyway oh my gosh how when when
am i supposed to get on in three minutes okay all right it's
okay we have three more minutes we have three more minutes
before i have to get on stage balk night but i better hear
you cheer for me loud i better hear you cheer i'm gonna make
sure if i if i'm out there performing and then i don't see
you jumping up and down and shaking a couple of these
dragons with your plastic sword oh man you're you're walking
home alone tonight also also i have to mention like after
today um i won't be streaming in the next maybe a couple of
months because i gotta get apex predator uh tonight so um
well i gotta get apex predator for uh season for season
three of apex legends so um i might have to take a hiatus
from streaming bark nights for maybe like next uh maybe i
don't know it might be like two to three months bark nights
but you'll be fine right i mean i took so many hiatuses
before You know, it's for Overwatch, for Apex, all that.
You can wait another couple of months, right?
You can't wait a couple of months this time.
Look, at least, you know, at least we're spending our last
day here at the concert, you know.
And you get to see my opening act.
Is that great?
Is that great, guys?
all right two more minutes okay oh backstage is calling me
but like you know i just got to get my guitar and then i'll
be fine but we have two more minutes guys to get what are
you guys all right bark nights all right bark nights um are
you excited i am excited too i'm sort of a little sick so
like i don't know how this is gonna go i'll be all right
okay but but if i don't sing well lie to me about it pretend
i am pretend is the best song you best singing you've ever
heard all right please leave me in ignorance i do not want
to know the truth because i am still a little sick so um the
singing might not be the most ideal and if so you better lie
about it you better me is the greatest song, greatest thing
you've ever heard.
It's the best cover of Avril Levine.
That's right.
Here, I'll let you guys practice right now.
I'll let you bark nights practice.
No lie.
Oh, you're so good at lying, guys.
You really are.
You guys are so good at lying.
I almost believe it.
all right oh it seems like the show is about to begin all
right i gotta go backstage park nights i'll see you guys
there okay i swear to god i swear to god i'll be looking at
the in the show the crowd for you guys all right all right i
want to go backstage now all right remember to shout my name
coming
well to be fair i was just the opening act but like thank
you everyone I hope you enjoyed, Girlfriend from Avril
Levine, saying by me, Dokibein.
All right, are y'all ready for the actual concept by Imagine
Dragons?
Then, let's get ready to rock!
All right, oh wait, hey, Park Night!
Park Night, hey!
Did you guys like this?
Do you guys like it, Park Nights?
Wow, Park Nights, are you okay?
Park Nights?
Are you okay?
You seem like you're about to...
It seems like you can't stand up right here, but are you...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Are you okay, Park Nights?
Park Nights?
Hey.
Dragoon.
Dragoon?
Are you...
Dragoon, wake up.
Wake up.
Dragoon, come on.
Come on.
We don't have insurance.
wake up dragon dragon we do not have insurance you gotta
wake up come on don't make me pour water on you oh
my god are you okay buddy are you okay look i know you
haven't like touched grass in a long ass time but like you
got me scared there man are you okay what you had a wild
dream or some What dream did you have?
What, you were like a black knight?
That was like, how many years ago was that?
You weren't even there during that time.
What do you mean?
A concert?
I never even did a concert back then.
Man, you got some wild-ass dreams, Dragon.
Come on.
I told you we were going to grab something at Doki Eats.
Take you back?
Bro, you can't.
don't want to go back i just like i stream like twice a
month and then i go on a five-month hiatus to play apex what
do you mean take you back you did not know how rough the
bark knights had it back then dragon like what are you
talking about
they were truly one of the strongest knights out there uh
She was so, what do you mean she was so perfect?
I'm right here!
She was me!
Oh my god.
I found one of my old skin suits to go out to celebrate our
anniversary and you were like, I miss old dokeybird.
I am old dokeybird.
She was me.
But anyway, oh my gosh, now that we're here, I have a very
exciting announcement to celebrate our second year
anniversary.
Yeah, while you were passed out in the streets of Dragoon
Alley, I managed to, I was setting up some stuff for us to
celebrate.
As you guys know, we are reopening the Doki merch store.
And if you see right behind me, don't worry, I'm going to
move a little bit.
If you see right behind me, you will see a particular
product behind me.
I would love to announce to all of you guys to celebrate the
relaunch of the Doki merch store.
Yes, that is right to celebrate the new Doki merch store.
We are announcing two more colors of the dog shirts because
we realized that the color was the problem.
So we're going to be selling more dog shirts in two more
colors.
Yes, you can get a dog shirt in green.
and red and also blue and green and don't worry I knew a lot
of the complaints from my previous dog shirt run was that um
was that there was not enough sizes so I'm happy to announce
that uh for this the new colors for the dog shirts uh we are
going to make shirt we have sizes small and extra small for
the chihuahuas for all everyone who owns chihuahuas and
those miniature poodles i got you because i know that that
is like that was the size that we were missing so now you
can get your dog shirts in extra small and small now yes
we're tripling down with the dog shirts anyway our real
announcement um to celebrate uh our second year anniversary
we have some very very cool merch that we've been working
very very hard on and this is coming from our new new
distributor um so we worked with our new distributor to come
up with uh the new merch uh for the second year anniversary
and it's something that a lot of you guys have been wanting
for a very long time um BAM!
Wow!
Do you guys recognize something really really cool in this
product photo?
Also, launch that store right now!
Alright, let me do a key merch is launched now.
Oh my god, the store is launched now.
Yes!
The store is now launched!
second year anniversary merch pre-order out now so yes for
the where did the where did my message go so I could pin it
the dokey coin is finally real finally my NFT is minted
my dokey coin is finally real so one of the coolest things
that really that I'm most excited to show you guys is
actually the little...
Wait, where's the picture that I saved?
Oh my gosh, is it a picture or a video?
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to find...
Oh wait, it was a video.
Let me grab the video.
So the cool thing I really wanted to show you guys is
actually the little tiny little dokey that you guys see
there because look at this.
God!
It's a...
Okay, don't mind the hair.
We're fixing that.
It's still on... It's still on a sampling period.
But it's a tiny Doki!
Yes!
The mark, the small... You can finally have your own
carry-on Doki to take you everywhere.
Also, roleplay finally over.
I hope you guys enjoyed my little...
my little skit um in the beginning um but no no the hair is
perfect oh but also this is a really cute part we have
little cape for hair you can put you can also use this for
your other tiny what do you mean that was real it was real
to me end scene by low
Patrick Efton, thank you for the Akasufa.
Oh my god, thank you for the carpet activated.
Oh my god, thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
But yes, so now, so you can also get a little dad cape, but
you can also put the cape.
Look, it has a tail.
Look at the tail.
Look at the tiny tail.
Oh my god, thank you, Brad.
Thank you.
and oh it's so cute and not only does it come in dad for him
but you can also if you buy the whole set you can also get a
little dragon too look at him oh my god thank you everyone
for the red carpet thank you guys thank you millers and
akasufa happy two years back thank you and it's a tale too
but also i was gonna i was gonna do a little poll a reason
for those in members um because this merch um this merch um
you know it's for you guys and also for me because then i
can bring a little doki everywhere and do little photos with
my with little me um but also because like i want to make
sure that uh you guys get the product that you want and i'm
gonna have a little vote right now actually of um of the the
little doki's face because we were struggling figuring out
like exactly like which face to choose uh because they all
look really all right so oh my gosh i wrote this down from
left to right is one two because we're gonna change you
wanted to like see which is the cutest so i'm gonna let you
guys you guys dragones to pick the face that you want for
little dokey because uh i know they're all they're really
good so it was so hard but I want so I want I decided since
we're still going through like um sampling period um I
wanted you guys to pick the face that you want because it's
your it's three okay I oh my god everyone wants three okay I
don't think I need a pull I don't I realize I don't think I
need a pull now I think everybody look I was stuck between
two or three I realized I don't need no nose so I was like
get rid of the nose but I was stuck between like two or
three on which one um on which one to do for it but all of
you guys want three I see most people pick three so I will
go uh manager manager son mr manager my manager did you hear
that they said three we will commit with three then
all right um I don't need no no but I like to all right
three all right so three we're gonna we're gonna commit with
three but anyway um my head is all over the place right now
so I guess I had no idea um I was so nervous going into this
okay before before okay before I start yapping and getting
emotional i want to show you guys this background look at
this oh sorry i'm gonna hide you guys real quick it's gonna
be animated it's gonna be animated later but uh obviously uh
uh we didn't have we didn't have time um to uh to have this
animated but like i worked with a new background artist for
this i'm so happy to find this background is because oh my
god this looks so good um but it hasn't animated yet but it
will be in the future but you guys like all the little
easter eggs uh i uh i asked alette to help out as well to
figure out some easter eggs but uh i was also brainstormed a
lot of little easter eggs uh to make this feel uh like very
me so you see there's like all the posters on the right and
on the left side and then finally doki eats is finally real
and then uh the little pork bun stall i was like i must have
a pork bun stall at the corner and then dad's little dog
shirt stall as well his little fucking dog shirt stall we
have too many dog shirts we need to get rid of them um so
he's out there busking right now he's out there being a
businessman um um and uh the inspiration for this I think
you guys can tell uh that the inspiration for this was uh um
the Hong Kong alleyway slash market uh markets um this is
why I gave the artist and I sent him a lot of reference
pictures as well and also the chat I was like very inspired
by like um China slash Hong Kong neon signs that you see
late at night through when you're walking through like the
blocks of the streets of Hong Kong or like the streets of
China that's what the that's what the chat was inspired by
it same with the same with the background as well like I
really wanted I thought I would fit the best yeah yeah fit
the best with the aesthetic that was going for like you know
post-concert we go we go to the to Hong Kong streets for
some Hong Kong street food.
This was exactly what I wanted to.
I was very detailed and specific on how I wanted like the
tables and the restaurants to look like.
So you can see the chairs.
If you ever looked up like Hong Kong street restaurants,
they use, they always use those square plastic chairs where
you can statin and then the circle wood, the circular wooden
tables and then the chopsticks with the square plastic
chairs and everything.
I was very specific on every little detail for this
background on how I just wanted it to, like, feel, like,
give you, like, nostalgic feeling of the streets of Hong
Kong.
And I'm glad that, like, I'm really happy with how this
turned out.
Yeah.
Yeah, the classic, like, square plastic.
white soles uh yeah that's the vibe i was going for and i'm
really happy with how it turned out um also um i hope you
guys liked i wanted to get like super creative uh with um
there's a lot of stuff i wanted to show you guys so
obviously we're gonna have our little greenstein stuff but
yes retro alt dokey is real she's finally real i was you
know um I was having um you know I was trying to figure out
like what do I want to do for my anniversary you know I was
just like oh what do I do for my anniversary what I've been
streaming for so even though it's my second year anniversary
I've been streaming for a while and I've done a lot of
anniversary streams a lot of birthday streams and like the
hardest part is always trying to think of like what do I do
next yeah for next year what what can I do uh for my next
anniversary or like my next milestone and I actually I
talked about this before but um oh yeah let me put up let me
make sure I put up the dokey bird anniversary I'll put this
here buy my merch too while i talk buy my merch and um i got
this idea um a month and a half ago i didn't plan this in
advance because like i can only go like one project at a
time um it's very i uh because like i said now that i'm
indie i've been much more busy behind the scenes with a lot
of stuff going on um so if i want whenever i want to do like
personal projects and stuff like that streams and everything
I actually do it one at a time nowadays in the past I was
able to multitask several things at the same time but uh now
that I'm an indie um I uh I have less I guess like less of
me to to spread around so so all of the stuff that I've done
for this stream in particular uh organizing everything a
huge shout out to all the people I've commissioned uh to
make this possible let me pull up the credits real quick um
like I said they made all of this in uh within a month and a
half so i had this idea a month and a half ago at the moment
new year's the new year stream ended uh the new year stream
ended i went straight into the anniversary planning being
like what the fuck do i am i gonna do what am i gonna do for
the anniversary so i went straight into this um coming up
with everything i wanted to do and uh everyone on this list,
so 3D animation, the, I want to actually add, like, they
actually finished the animation.
The animation and the music video, and even, like, the
rigging, all of it was done today, like, fully finalized
everything, done today.
I think the one thing that was finished early was the
background.
The background itself was the only one that was finished
early.
Oh, and the teaser and the debut teaser.
So huge shout out to everyone for working so hard.
I'm making it in time.
But yes, there's 3D animation.
You might recognize them.
There is a team that I usually, the team I always, I usually
work with for stuff like this, especially for events.
And 3D animation.
I wanted to add more to it, but we were at this point where
we actually were like, we finished the animation today.
But originally in my head, I wanted an ending to it.
like at the end of the cell you passing out um it's like you
guys uh there will be a small animation at the end where
like you guys get home and you're tired and you fall asleep
and then you wake up back as a dragoon and that's how i
wanted like originally in my head that's how i wanted to end
it at that time like um there wasn't enough time so i felt
like you know the one where after the concert i was like are
you guys okay wake up whoa you guys you guys look like
you're about to pass So, you know, I was like, that's how
I'm going to end the story.
And then sound design was Mr. Fox, background artist,
Volkiri, Puscia, to them.
I was just browsing my Twitter.
I think you guys might notice I follow a lot of artists on
Twitter.
Like, 90% of the people I follow in my following thing are
artists.
is literally just artwork mostly artwork memes and fortnite
uh and sometimes rivals it's memes art fortnite skins and
then sometimes rivals um so i i get a lot of like artist
recommendations so um i'm so happy that the twitter
algorithm graced me with uh valkyrie for the backgrounders
because like this background looks fucking amazing there's
so much personality to it i cannot wait to see this animated
too um i love like like they've never really been they've
never really done like background art for vtubers before
either like they've done like art commissions um but they've
never done like background commissions for i think i was
like their first back like vtuber commission um so um huge
shout out to them for able to slip me in by the way their
commissions were closed and i was like um i know your
commissions this even though when someone's twitter profile
they say their commissions are closed i always be like um i
know your commissions are closed but like uh can i
commission you for this I was just like, um, you done.
I'm just going to shoot my shot and just wanted to ask if
you're commissioned, if you could slip me in and you're
cute.
Thanks, Tengen.
I know, it's been so long.
Yeah.
And they did an amazing job.
I really love, I love like how much personality the entire
background has and like working with me.
Like, and when I gave them ideas, for Easter eggs also you
shut up not I didn't put them on the credits list um but I
also message outlet for uh fellow dragon by the way you
might recognize them um they also helped out on Doki line
before but I message outlet for like help with thinking of
some Easter eggs as well and let me pull up uh they like
sent me uh oh my gosh where is it they were like on vacation
and they sent me like a sketchbook of like ideas that we
could possibly use um for the background and um originally I
didn't have the tomato chef and I was like oh Alec no Alec
Alec um not Alec I'm sorry Alec but wasn't you and um I took
their tomato chef idea which you can see right down there
and then also like the tv to the tv the tomato chef the
tomato club dish as well so you see that dragon there um i
fucking miss tomato club so much um it's having uh a clap
the tomato club classic over there the tomato noodle soup um
everything so huge shout out to outlet for helping out with
helping me with figuring out uh little easter eggs for this
background what else what else did i want to tell you oh
yeah and then um she go for the art checky props so like the
little photos that we had and everything those little the
little checkies that we have also claire helped me a lot
because claire drew the little hands on the on the little
checkies because i uh i forgot to ask about the little hands
and then i asked claire because she was still online if she
could draw the little hands and stuff to make it more
immersive and stuff like that so Thank you for drawing the
little checkies for us.
The Klayer and Shigo.
Because they look really good.
And then debut teaser, retrovis.
Yes, it was by Klayer.
The original.
Oh, my mouse died.
I was like, PC died or mouse died?
Sorry, my mouse died.
Let me charge my mouse.
At least I'm not playing an FPS game right now.
um mclea she is my original mama my original mama for retro
doki and um like i said i came up with this idea like i
think um end of december or early january and i was like do
you think you could make it in time and she was like yes and
then she made she literally we got everything done today and
so she did make it in time oh yeah here let me show you guys
i do have have an afk animation
so we do have a couple of upgrades we do have a couple of
upgrades so yes it is uh my original mama um does that mean
retro dokey is back it might means that retro alt dokey is
back uh retro dokey will make might come out for special
occasions but it doesn't mean that she is back back but
retro alt dokey it um is here new new toy our new toy so
that means retro alt dokey uh might um show up in streams
now regularly uh because it is my new toy uh my new skin
suit there's hope uh new and improved but also old um so uh
so that means we will see retro alt dokey in future streams
um and what else what else but yes the original outfit
design for those who have never seen the original outfit
design um this was a fan favorite the alt dokey um outfit
was a fan favorite for retro dokey will return in adventures
and game ash thank you i was thinking for the super chat
thank you thank you so retro dokey was a fan favorite for a
outfit for a very long time and i decided for the
anniversary uh to celebrate our two years i decided to make
her real the retro alt dokey is real guys and i don't know i
thought like you know i think that was like a thing that a
lot of dragoons have wanted for a very long time and i was
like you know that i was just like thinking like you know
what we're i'm gonna fucking i'm gonna do it fuck it fuck
that i'm gonna fucking do it and i did it and i did and i'm
here now i'm real she's real now um and i thought it was a
great way to celebrate the second year anniversary also the
cover too i think the cover was also um i know um um Like,
for the cover song, I was very nervous about it because,
also, huge shout out to the mixers and the instrumental and
the harmonies from my go-to mixing team, Asteroid Music
Team, so Johnny, Moni, and Ari, a huge shout out to all of
them for making me sound good and not terrible.
I really appreciate it, that I do not sound like a dying
cat, like, in my raw recordings.
so huge shout out to them for making me sound um sound like
you know actually listenable
i was very very nervous about the cover um because um i need
you guys to know i recorded this i recorded the song two
weeks ago um the mv was being made for an entire month and a
half but like the song itself was recorded two weeks ago
because if you guys don't remember I got sick in the
beginning of January I was planning on recording that like
in the first week of January um when before I got sick and
then when I got sick I was like okay that's all right as
long as I don't get the usual lingering cough um it should
be fine because I can just record after I'm not sick and
then and then as we all know that that happened i i got the
lingering cough and i still do i was coughing in the morning
when i woke up and um i was like that's okay maybe the cough
is just like two to three days you know like but but it
wasn't two to three days guys i think it's been a month now
and i was like oh that's all right maybe let's just I'll
just wait a week and then it'll go awake And then it'll go
away And that week went by And it didn't go away So I was
like Alright maybe two weeks you know Maybe two weeks I
still have time And then at that point After two weeks I was
like Fuck I actually really need to record this song So at
least like they need time To salvage whatever the fuck this
is And it always happens.
Every time I want to record a song, I get sick.
I swear to God, 90% of the songs I've released or sang or,
like, recorded, I got sick before recording.
And, like, it's like God's way of being like, you should
stop singing.
You were not meant to sing.
Why do you keep singing after I keep getting you sick?
I feel like it's like life telling me something but anyway
um I was actually I was still coughing yeah that was me
nerfed by the way I was still coughing while I was recording
that song I picked a day where I woke up and I was like I'm
not I'm not coughing as much I I I made a lot I made hot tea
honey and honey and water um and then chugged that down and
then made another bottle of water hot water and then had the
mapego the like the the chinese herbal medicine for your
throat had that too and then got like sucked on a cough drop
to make sure and then i went to recording i tried everything
i was like all right if i'm still sick or pee pie pie pie go
sorry that's what it's called and i was like at that point i
gave up i was like okay i'm still I'm still sick, but like
we'll make do with what we have
We'll just we'll just fuck it we'll just roll with this Um,
so you shouted them I was very I I was really nervous about
that song because like I said I was I recorded it when I was
still very sick and I still am very sick Um, um, so they
were able to make it sound like a real song and I really
appreciate uh the i really appreciate that they were able to
do this um also another huge shout out to the mv artwork and
the mv on mica and raring uh for the artwork of the music
video as well as the visuals the video edits um you know how
that we had the little concert here i'll show you guys like
uh we had this and this um this literally i had this idea
well i had this idea like five hours before the stream but
then um the editor went to sleep went to bed so then um they
woke up an hour before the stream and exported um the videos
of this the looping videos of this so huge shout out to them
because i had this idea literally five hours before the
stream i was like oh my god because i didn't want to i
didn't want to
do I transition?
I was like thinking for a very long time, I was like, how do
I transition to the music video?
And then my like this idea popped up because I remembered,
oh wait, like we have the scene from the music video, you
know, like this part from the music video with everybody
like cheering in the background and like the concert hall
and everything.
And I remember this in the video.
So I was just like, oh my gosh, okay, wait, if I have this,
I can use that as a transition transition to the concert
part.
And then I was like, how do I lead you to the MV?
So I was like, oh, wait, what if we just have this screen?
Because I didn't want to end stream and then like raid
the...
I didn't want to make two anniversary streams.
I figured it'd be better if I just have the premiere playing
while like this stream was going on.
And then we have like this little thing.
This little thing to be like, click on the link, guys.
Click on it.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Me will like to wish you a happy anniversary.
Thank you for wishing a happy anniversary.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
So huge shout out to the editor for managing, for getting
all of that for me.
What else?
What else is there?
But yeah, Bark Nights by our usual 3D modeler Hasks.
The thumbnail was by Voyager Gears.
So I love the thumbnail that they made for the anniversary
stream.
And the chat was done by...
what do you do yeah huge shout out to everybody that worked
really really hard um for this anniversary don't worry the
chat's not frozen here oh my gosh oh yes this i have to show
you guys this so as you guys know the plush is going oh yeah
by the way all right we have a lot of new stuff i told you
new toy look at this i can oh wait give me All right, give
me a sec.
Let's see.
Oh, my gosh.
Give me a sec.
Let me pull this up.
Woo.
There he is.
Look at him.
Now I have that here, too.
But I can also hold him.
Oh, my gosh.
Not like that.
Whoops.
oopsie um well i mean once i wanted to show you this i can
also hold him like this too look at him look at him he's
showing his belly he's so submissive look at this little guy
you know he's so cute i'm so cute and they're like i
couldn't pick between the two so so I was like fuck it I
mean I'm indie now I can I can ask as many toggles as I want
um so I I brought back a a fan favorite too look at this
Cleo was like is there anything else you want to add and I
was like yes I need eye bags for how I actually feel for how
my soul truly feels every day is how i feel every time i
turn i wake up and i clock in and yeah and then i could have
it without the dead eyes you know where my this sparkle in
my eye is gone now but i said the joy yeah she's been doing
this for so long the sparkle is gone
Oh, toky.
The too many Marvel rivals.
She's just like us.
The joy is gone from her eyes.
What else?
I have, oh yes, I actually have two.
I thought this was really cute because I wanted something
like I don't know I just wanted like another glasses toggle
another new glasses prop and I thought this was real cute
but I can also but I can also be a nerd don't worry I also
have the nerd toggle here too so I have two pairs of glasses
one for nerds and one for hanging out um thank you uh
takodachi thank you the super chat thank you your new look
is so dark thank you thank you thank you I unfortunately do
not have the toggle you wish for rice thank you the super
chat thank you thank you um but I do have um there will be a
do kitty uh feature in the in the future but not today
because like I said uh we just managed to finish everything
um with all the current requested stuff today so do kitty
will be a done in the future another new thing that you guys
might have seen during the photo shoot was
i can do it as a like part of my face so i can be like or or
as a toggle
by the way originally this tongue was very long it was like
all the way to the bottom of my chin and i was like claire i
think you gotta make that shorter i i don't think that's
appropriate i
i was like claire i don't think that's appropriate i think i
might need that tongue a little Jordan so she cut it in half
yeah it was a little it was a two a little bit too freaky so
I had to I had to nerf the power I had to nerf the power
level oh oh yeah so I oops I really want to show you guys
this because I thought it was really funny so um for those
um who've never seen who never uh i'll show you guys like an
inside look of manufacturing and uh working with
manufacturers and stuff because um for those who've never
worked with manufacturers um it's a lot especially for
plushies it's a lot of trial and error and a lot of back and
forth and i must show you the very first iteration of this
plushie.
I shall show you a little behind the scenes on how we got
here.
Like, all right, so this was how the plush ended up.
I'll show you guys what the plush looks like now and then
like the comparison between the two.
I think it was this.
So, oh, this is with the cape.
So, um, it is currently at a pre-order period, but I knew,
uh, my manager, wait, is he still awake?
He said, he's still awake.
Manager!
manager how long is pre-order period manager all right this
is actually not the finished version by the way but like
this is our newest sample that we have received from our
manufacturer so uh from the so but i'll show you the very
first sample we've ever got um because it's
i'll show you the adventure of mini doki i'll show you the
adventures of little doki and how she got here how she came
to be um and she's not even finished by the way so this was
the very first draft that we received from the manufacturer
this is the very first concept we got and you're like oh
that's the first draft surely it would get better right um
and then this was the second one
we got because we're like this doesn't look very right and
then why didn't you stick with this one okay oh no my god um
so then i was we were like okay this sort of doesn't look
right um um
yeah but how long is the pre-order period or is the
pre-order period until uh how long is it yeah and then and
then we're like oh man this sort of something off about this
get this dokey there's something wrong with this dokey
anyway so after that this was finally this was a the this
was the third version um you're like oh hey she looks normal
and then you realize how wide the hair the back of the hair
is it's like i went fucking super saiyan i'm like
wow it's a super super saiyan dokey also uh my manager just
told me it's a one month order period uh one month order
period uh for the anniversary merch And Super Saiyan 3,
Doki.
Yeah.
So we're like, yeah, I think the hair needs to be a little
shorter.
And now we're here.
Now this is Doki number 4.
Please also release the first draft.
You mean this one?
He doesn't even have clothes on.
This is like not even Doki Beta.
Doki Alpha 0.01
So that is Doki, the very first Doki Plush that led to the
second to release the original Doki.
Leave her out loud.
That's the point.
Doki Prime.
Release Doki Plush.
prime it's not even dead this time it's like a fucking ditto
trying to attempt to copy me alright anyway if I don't know
if I'd call her alpha alright other than that we also have
this is something I'm also very excited about also yes if
you guys can see from this the vase will be changing to
number three so say goodbye to her nose because we will be
removing her nose and then the face will be the third number
three uh i believe this is three right this is the one you
guys all vote for right left to right one two three and
three is this right free do toky toky has achieved god for
the first toky to step on lad is this toky three so it's
going to look like this the face will look like this in the
for those who are wondering.
No, they got her.
We deleted her nose.
She don't need to smell anything.
Smelling doesn't benefit anyone.
Like, what's the point with having a nose?
What does having a nose do for us anyway?
Like, who needs to actually smell things?
Anyway, anyway.
So this is not the final draft, and we will have Doki number
five.
And Doki number 5 will most likely look like this.
But yeah, that was the process.
A little behind the scenes look of...
How do I word this?
A little behind the scenes look on the process of Mini Doki.
Other than that, another thing I'm super excited about to
show you guys is...
The Doki coin!
Yeah!
It's finally real!
I can't endorse by the Doki bank.
Yes, my NFT is finally real.
It's minted and everything.
My dokey coin.
My, my Bitcoin.
To the moon.
We go.
It's real.
My cryptocurrency is finally real.
But other than that, another thing, my favorite thing about
this uh about the doki coin is that it has a back print by
the way it doesn't not not only does it have uh a front side
but um it also has a it has a heads and a tail so it's not
just you know it's just not just me on the back side um is
also a drag is like uh uh our dragons i don't know let me
see if the store has it yeah so you can see it in the you
can see it on the listing itself, but it has a back and a
front print.
And I think my favorite part about, all right, let me, I'll
grab the images real quick.
Let's see.
All right, I'm refreshing.
Here, this is what it looks like.
Yeah, this is the backside of the coin.
So there is a heads and a tails.
And my favorite part about the Goki coin is the box, which i
designed myself guys like this has my full uh the box was uh
designed entirely by me and i worked very hard on it
i worked incredibly hard on the box design guys uh i
specifically requested that we use comic sounds um as the
subtitles uh
um all right let me but yeah i am very excited about my
anniversary merch um uh i was uh uh it's something i've
always wanted to do like the merch is very personalized and
everything like a lot of stuff that i've always wanted to do
for my merch and stuff like no more no more dog shirts this
time like these are things that i know you guys actually
would what oh yeah also i Clea had time to make an
illustration for us.
So there's going to be an acrylic block illustrated by my
mama slash papa, Clea, my OG mama papa.
And she made this wonderful, beautiful artwork.
And it's going to be an acrylic block.
So it's a 3D.
There's like, what's the word?
Like a 3D look to it.
Everything like that in the front, me in the middle, and
then the background in the back and everything.
And also, if you buy the entire set, you buy the entire set,
you'll get a free postcard, a free postcard, and it will, it
won't be signed, but it will have, yeah, Laird, sorry, it's
Laird, so, sorry, I'm tired, I, leading up to this
anniversary, my brain is tired, but it will be a forward
print with a special little message, a special little
message, that personally hand-written.
And it will be a foil print on the postcard.
If you buy the entire set.
I think it's really cute that...
Like, I've always wanted to have, like, little...
I'm glad we were able to do the little capes thing, too.
The little cape with Dad and the Dragoons.
So you buy the set, you get this cheaper as well.
And also, like, oh, my God, look.
You can have all your little plushies.
We're Dragoon capes, too.
You can have...
Technically, you can have an army of...
Dragoons, if you think about it, you can have an army of
dragoons with your little plushies.
They can all wear, they can all wear their little capes.
And it fits the other tiny plushies.
If you ever like, and then you have like those mint plushies
too.
The capes will fit on them as well.
That's specifically designed to fit like the little, like
the little finger, like the little puppet plushies.
So I know they're like really popular.
in japan and in asia so you don't like own like a lot of
these little plushies and everything all the capes should
fit them um but yeah oh my gosh i'm so happy about the merch
day my anniversary i think all of it looks amazing and
everybody worked so hard um doing all of this i had some
crazy ideas and we were able to especially for those who
don't know um usually manufacturers uh close really early
because of chinese new year so the fact that to get these
ideas out and like be able to um be able to you know make it
to this far before factories go on vacation uh for chinese
new year is like such a huge accomplishment that we were
able to show any of these progress photos for you guys um so
it's not just you know it's not just like a concept or
anything we do have samples um we do have these samples like
uh being made already uh and we're getting close to having
it done especially the plushies too um um what else what
else did i want to tell you guys talk to you guys about
others oh yeah okay i i worked really hard on trying to make
the merch affordable for all of you guys because um um i
actually have to fight my uh the our distributor and my
manager about it about the pricing Because, like, I want to
make sure my merch is affordable for all of you guys.
Because the plushie was originally priced at, I think it was
priced at, like, $40.
And I was like, no!
It was like $35 or $40.
And I was like, I refuse to have the plushies priced that
high.
Because I was like, I was, like, researching how other
people were pricing their merch stuff and stuff.
so I like negotiated and um bargained uh with my distributor
and my manager to have it lower to $25 instead uh to make it
more affordable for all of you guys a 25 USD um it was
originally 40 I think it was either 35 or 40 USD and I said
that was too much and I was like I like had a long
discussion with all of them and I was like it I wanted to be
$25 and um the risk for it is that we're going to be
ordering a lot of the mini plushies and they're like this is
a huge gamble are you sure and i was like yes i am sure so
if i'll be if i am selling these mini plushies for the next
three years uh that's on they're like that's on me and i oh
no it's gonna be like but it's not the dog shirt this time
it's not gonna be like the dog shirts guys it's not gonna be
like the dog marketable trust the process the mini plushies
are much more marketable than than the dog shirts like it
won't be the same um um yeah so like the coins too the coins
were originally wait how how much are they now i don't
remember the coins were oh my gosh it's at cad so i need to
look at the United States yeah the coins were originally uh
I think it was originally like 35 or 40 and I lowered it to
20 as well because like like I said like I want to be I want
to make sure that you know um my merch is affordable for you
dragons and even though I might not make a lot of profit
like um I want you guys to enjoy the merch and like like,
um, to enjoy the merch and, um, you know, make lots of great
memories as well.
And, um, and I was like, I want things to be affordable for
you guys.
Like I said, I said before, I'm not here.
I don't want to, like, you know, I don't want to, like, milk
my fans for stuff.
I still want to have, uh, I still want, like, uh, you guys
to be able to, you know, uh, cause it, you know, what's the
weird, I'm, it's like, eh.
um oh my gosh it's like i just want things to be like i
don't want you guys to spend like your entire savings on on
like my merch and stuff i want you guys to be able to have
enough money have enough money to uh to like be able to
afford your daily needs daily necessities and stuff like
that and uh being able to uh oh what am i oh a video being
able to like you know like like the dokey merch is just like
a little plus and stuff just like little memories of stuff
of our time together and everything um and so yeah i i like
uh i fought with my distributor and my manager to be like no
because they're like what about 25 and i was like no 20 take
it or leave it And they're like, how about 25 dollars?
Like, no!
I demand for the coin to be $20.
But yeah, I tried my best to lower...
Do not let me...
Do not let me reveal how much it cost to me.
So...
So I do hope you guys enjoy the merch.
Like I said, it's only gonna be on the store for...
One month and I what pre-orders will only be on the store
for one month as well.
Oh Yeah, oh my wait, I don't message my manager about it.
Can I
God leave some money for us to super chat and buy the
membership.
Thank you Doki Naraka.
Thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I Sorry, I just wanted to see if I have permission
to talk about this.
Okay.
Okay, I can't.
My manager's like, okay, I was like, can I talk about this
other thing?
And my manager's like, no.
I'd rather you not talk about this other thing.
Solid Snake, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats on your second anniversary, just like my old chef
fell the nap gotcha but my soul woke me up just in time for
this song um for reasons like this exactly why i love you
being part of uh part of your dragoons you're still as
amazing as when i met you keep being awesome thank you thank
you thank you thank you everybody for all the super chats
guys i'm sorry if i couldn't read them in time my head is
all over the place right now oh
um thank you guys for the support and for watching me right
now and uh for hanging out with me today um uh but yeah uh
um i really appreciate everyone who buys merch um i have
said this before but uh even though i have priced it lower
than what my distributor wanted um for those who don't know
merch is like one of the um no one of the number one uh is
like i guess like one of the main sources of income for a
lot of people uh because uh merch is like a big portion of
uh of a lot of people's like a lot of streamers income
that's why a lot of people do merch and stuff so thank you
everybody um for um for buying my merch it really does help
a lot and i hope you guys enjoy the stuff i make uh and the
stuff that i produced and worked on with my distributor too
like i try to make things that i think that uh yeah It's a
very like a lot it makes it's oh my gosh, my brain I need a
thesaurus right now my thesaurus my brain Thesaurus is not
working my brain dictionary is not working.
I cannot formulate sentences at the moment I keep being like
what what am I what do I want to say like I'm not locked in
in streamer mode right now I
But my streamer mindset is not on right now.
I'm so I'm like I'm so chill at the moment
but um but i do hope i try to think of merch for this
anniversary that's more so like stuff that dragoons wanted
like obviously i know you guys all what like those you guys
have always wanted those little mini plushies that you can
um bring around um um like those mini plushies can bring
take photos with like take your doki around the world type
yeah and also i did too i always wanted like i've been
bringing my giant ass doki plushies with me like my uh my
good smile joki plushies with me for photos and stuff but
like it's not very convenient not gonna lie it takes up i
have to bring a giant ass bag to fit my giant ass doki but
now i can have a mini toky now i could bring the mini toky
everywhere and i could fit her in a i can fit her in a purse
too and like yeah and then like show everyone that my who my
oh she is which is me obviously i'm my number one fan and be
like yeah that's my oh she that's my oh she she's me um um
but yeah but Oh, thank you guys.
Yeah, my own portable, my own portable doki.
Travel size.
Yeah, my travel size portable doki plushie.
Can the mini doki wear a dog shirt?
I feel like you could actually buy a dog shirt and then like
use the fabric to make a little mini shirt for the doki.
For the mini doki.
If someone does that, please take a photo and posted in the
tags i really want to see a little a little jokie wearing
the tiny little dog shirt that would be so fucking funny
that's how you are going to sell them guys please buy my dog
shits i have look i'm making dad out there busking right now
look at him he look at him he's trying he's working so hard
trying to
I'm making him work on a Saturday night.
We have too many dog shirts.
He's just trying to sell this shirt.
He has to hustle.
He's out there hustling.
Do it for dad.
Yeah, thank you guys.
Thank you all for being here.
For two years technically long.
but happy 12 year anniversary guys because not only a
celebration of me and this channel but also a celebration of
our community and um and you guys too there won't be a jokie
bird without you dragons here uh supporting me all the way
to the end um but yeah it really does mean a lot to see so
many dragons um give up their business these schedules to
hang out with me on this saturday night um and putting up
with my stupid skits my my little my little role play
session with all of you guys uh
and and also like you know cheering me on with my cover my
new cover song uh hey hey you you are me a oh my gosh if
this if this bot gets struck by abriel levine because i
actually played 10 seconds of her song i will be so sad i
will be so sad i forgot i forgot that the i forgot that you
guys could hear the video playing on stream because i you
know there are so many things going on in my head that of
course the one thing I fuck up on the one thing is having a
copyright song playing on this stream oh it's like freebirds
all over again you know the amount of ad money I could have
got on that stream if freebird never played like oh my god
they made so much money off of that one stream
I'm gonna have to re-upload the pot.
Oh my god.
Please, Abriel Levine.
You don't need more of my money.
Every anniversary, you just get copyrighted.
What else?
What else did I want to show?
Oh yeah, let me check my folder.
I downloaded a lot of stuff on my folder, so I just want to
be sure.
There's anything else I want to show.
Oh yeah, yeah, I forgot to show you guys this.
This is his design.
Did you like it?
He doesn't have his dog tag because it ripped off his ear.
But he has his little earrings.
Just a bad boy.
He has his little earrings.
And his shirt says dad.
A little notched ear.
And then here are some concepts of the concept art of what
he could have looked like.
yeah so uh we pivoted from the like this was what claya came
up with at first but i was like i gave like a different
suggestion because i wanted him to look more like a like
like more like gough punk like punk rock type deal so that's
why we have the little spike collar and the little spike
collar and the classic like stripped t-shirt the stripped
t-shirt with the spiky collar and and i think he looks looks
pretty rad now oh yeah also the bonus artwork from the music
video the artist drew this like drew this in her free time
um um and then we took that idea with the polaroids and
stuff uh she because like she drew this at first as like a
little little bonus art um it was like little bonus noodle
and then we're like oh wait the polar idea is so funny let's
add that into the music video.
And my favorite part was when Dragoon Doki taped her face
over the girlfriend Dragoon.
And that's one of my favorite scenes in the music video.
What else?
What else I want to show you guys?
uh this woman oh my god i can't believe jokie pride i wish i
actually have this i actually sort of wish i had the sample
but i think they like after we were like um this this this
this doesn't look right i'm pretty sure they like
deconstructed it and reused the fabric for another thing
like sky welcome to the tomato fire welcome will dokey prime
she's so cool
and then it is super saiyan dokey
oh yeah guys i don't think dokey prime is alive no more all
right i gotta use the bathroom guys i'll be back
all right i'm back guys oh i forgot to mention oh my gosh
wait let me grab the yes to celebrate the anniversary um i
asked the music video editor if they could provide me with
uh seals of uh seals from the music video to use as
wallpapers so so for everybody if you guys want to use any
of the artwork as wallpapers from the music video.
You can download it right now!
So you can use any of the any of the stills from the music
video as your wallpaper too.
Yeah!
That first jokie is the first in the evolution line.
Therefore his name shall be jokie.
Sorry, Ace.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's her name?
Um...
Amen.
Missing link name.
What was her name?
The missing link?
She's the missing link.
Lucy!
She's the...
She's Lucy Bird!
The first Stokey.
She's the missing link.
That's Lucy right there.
The missing link.
primordial doki.
This is primordial doki.
This is um, which one is this?
This one is
uh, this is Neanderthal doki.
They got wiped out by the way.
Uh, this doki got wiped out uh, by, by by doki sapien.
We have we have lucy bird we have doki the neanderthal and
then we have doki sapien which was doki sapien would be like
be like this the
one true doki and then doki sapien's gonna get killed off
anyway she's so cold erect this toky toky porcelain getting
bigger by the way for those who are new year your plushies
will not look like this i i swear to god the plushies
already on his fourth stage of sampling guys your plushie
will not look like this it will look like this for those who
are new year it will look like this but the face will be as
a disclaimer the face will be like number three.
It'll be like this.
So the fourth stage of sampling.
Why?
Now I'm going to cancel my order.
I thought the plushie was going to look like the first one.
Now I'm disappointed.
No!
But what if I want it to look like this?
Doki 3, aka San Doku.
Thank you for the super chat.
papa thank you thank you oh the four stages of toky blood oh
yeah next week i wish i could spoil you guys on what's gonna
be happening on next week but um i will be streaming on
monday that's all i can say i can't say exactly what i'll be
doing on monday but wait actually i think i can wait
actually wait let me make sure I don't know and I can't
remember anything anymore I guys like a hundred million
things are going on at the same time right now behind the
scenes so I like I could barely remember what I can and
can't say because like I have so many NDAs and contracts
I've signed and I'm just like am I allowed to say this now
like and I'm like all the dates have blurred together that I
can't on when my NDA ends.
I can't keep track anymore.
There's too many contracts.
All right.
Too many contracts.
I need a...
No, my manager is my spreadsheet.
Why read my own...
Why read and make my own spreadsheet?
If my manager is my chat GPT, I'm like, at manager, do I,
can I talk about this?
All right, okay, all right, I can talk about it.
All right, I talked to my manager PT, manager GPT, and he
said that I can say that on Monday, I was like, I didn't
know if I could say it.
On Monday, I will, oh, shit, okay.
On Monday, I was invited to do the early access of the
newest Apex season.
So that's what I'll be doing on Monday.
And then on Wednesday, I will be doing something else that's
also early access.
And then on Saturday, let's see.
Oh, yes, it's back.
We're back to our...
We're coming back.
And on Saturday, it's Dad's birthday!
Yeah!
And Dad told me he has something very exciting planned for
all of you guys.
I had something exciting planned for you guys for the second
year anniversary.
Dad has something very exciting planned for you guys for his
birthday.
So yeah, I hope you guys all come and celebrate my dog's
birthday because I pushed a tournament.
for him they're like we won't have a tournament on saturday
i'm like i'm sorry that's my dog's birthday i i can't do
that so so we pushed the tournament just for him um yeah and
then the tournament is after dad's birthday uh oh oh yeah
another thing sorry i have like staff messaging me another
thing dokey jam stuff for everyone that has participated in
dokey jam um the freebie stuff is being sent out right now
and a lot some people have already received uh their dokey
jam freebies so and everybody who have participated in dokey
jam the game jam the dokeyberg game jam um some people have
already received their sticker and postcard uh from the
dokey jam because every participant gets a sticker and uh
gets a sticker and postcard so i just received a message
that people have already received it also dad does not get
his own merch unfortunately um because his dog shirts do not
sell so i'm sorry dad uh your merch privileges has been
revoked i'm sorry dad you're just not marketable enough
maybe one day maybe one day so i will let you guys know like
he unfortunately will not be distributing he will not have
any special merch announcement next week guys he
unfortunately lost his merch privileges because his dog
sheds did not sell enough so uh we have revoked his
privilege with merch privileges time for dad to go indie
time to leave dokeycorp dad you deserve better
but dokey what if you made a life-size dad plushie that
wears a dog shirt next day thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you um can i oh yeah yeah i forgot green
screen time green screen time thank you for reminding me
duck can i request a green screen of course all right it's
green screen time i knew i forgot to do something all right
i mean i have so many scenes now on this surprise my pc has
not exploded yet uh oh maybe that's why my pc keeps dying i
do like my entire career is a stress test all right here you
um it's urple because my eyes are green but all right no
wait i shouldn't hold all right let me take dad down all
right goodbye dad all right
poses um you know like those like video have you ever seen
that uh the most what was that vid uh who was that model
like this uh tick tock model chinese tick tock model who was
like the most requested tick tock shop model because like
she would do like uh was so good at posing with merch
because it will only take her like five seconds or something
per pose um and she was like really good at pushing product
because of how fast she fucking she can fucking give
different poses every time it's like me it's like
yeah yeah yeah her oh yeah well i'll have like my like my
default expressions i've had originally on uh Retro-Doki,
so...
So there's a smug one.
And then...
Confused.
Please buy my dog shirts.
And then...
Oh.
Is that...
Money.
I see.
whoa oh my god that's a lot of money and then
um oh yeah and this is a classic the hard hands uh in the
past as retro dokey uh because I was a very small streamer
back then um whenever I got a follow I'll give a little hard
hand like oh thank you for the follow um here's a little
heart so that's why i had this i had this toggle made so i
was like thanking people for every follow i got because it
was very rare when someone follows me because i was a very
small streamer back then um and also the clap i forgot what
was the point oh yeah for subscribing and then on because i
was on twitch too i was twitch streamer so every time when
someone subscribed to me on Twitch, I was like, thank you
for subscribing.
And I was like, give them a little, thank you for the sub.
And I gave them a little clap to be like, thank you.
And oh yeah, there's the bong.
I had like a little redeem where you can bong me.
I'd be like, bong.
And then a little dancing.
Yay.
Because I got lazy.
Like, you know, like when you're like, I don't want to move
my body.
Oh yeah, here's the glasses.
Eh.
activated yeah that's right and then and i could put this on
and off so like if i feel really really cool today i mean
like oh today is so good well next scene thank you for the
akka i don't know i don't know if it overlaps but i can try
but thank you for the akka soup but thank you thank you
Unfortunately, I'm sorry.
It doesn't overlap.
Confuse overpowers, Dua.
Confuse.
Confuses the alpha.
It's a little...
It's so cold.
Wow.
And then this can be a toggle to him.
And...
Or...
Um...
I wish I had a screenshot of my very long tongue.
It was crazy.
I don't have the...
The skin suit anymore.
Maybe I could ask Clay...
Wait, I don't know if Clay is back yet.
Yeah, no, she's not back.
But maybe I could show you guys in another stream.
But, like, that tongue went all the way to my chin.
It was fucking crazy.
It was a very long tongue.
And I was like, Clay, we got a short in that tongue.
I was like, your's dad.
here's dad here he is it's like i could almost chuck him in
the air immediately whoa making like a little pancake look
at him he's showing his belly he's so submissive right now
look at him so submissive and then there's him uh because it
looked weird what do you mean why did i change it It looked
fucking weird.
It didn't right.
It didn't look right.
And there's him again.
There's that again.
And then there's just eye bags.
And then when the joy leaves my body.
When it fully, there's no more whims.
When there's no more whimsy in the world.
There's a little whimsy still.
I still have hope for the world.
Whimsy is God.
There's...
The whimsy is God.
You should have thought...
No, it was so fucking weird.
No, when you see it, it didn't look right.
That's your message.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, what else?
What else?
Oh, yeah.
And in this, wait, am I still, like, dead inside?
No, I'm not.
Okay, I was like, wait, no, I still look dead inside.
Okay, no, I'm fine now.
In 2026, Wimsy is dead.
I love the, I love the little, the glasses on.
It's a little tint on it, too.
I look so cool.
I don't look like a shut-in.
I look like I touch grass regularly, guys.
For real.
Definitely not a lie.
Yeah.
I'm so cool.
Do you need a nerdy glasses next?
All right.
There you go.
And then the one time, I was like, oh my gosh, I know what 2
plus 2 is.
God, I'm so smart.
Happy anniversary, Doki.
Can we get a wink?
Of course.
Thank you for the magenta soup budget.
Thank you.
Hey, what about my glasses?
Oh, wait, that's cute.
I love the tongue.
I love the tongue, Taga.
It's really cute.
All right.
Any other special requests, guys?
Any other special requests that you guys have?
make it okay other than that any special request unrelated
to the tongue and it's like everyone lowers their hand
wink plus i just did wink plus tongue look we don't have the
jesus special unfortunately okay legs all right i i will
entertain that all right where we were Okay.
Yeah.
This is what it looks like.
And then these are the legs.
Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah, the shoes got an upgrade, by the way.
Like some punk rock shoes too.
We got an upgrade on the shoes.
And then, oh yeah, full body.
Oh yeah, wait, let me do a look.
Yay!
Whoa!
Hey, hey, you, you.
I'm your girlfriend.
Bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada.
Hey, hey, you, you.
Oh yeah, it was And we got a show for you Veggie Tales,
Veggie Tales, Veggie Tales Veggie tails, veggie tails,
veggie tails, veggie tails, veggie tails, broccoli, celery,
something, something, veggie tails.
Veggie tails, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, vegetables.
There we go.
There you go.
Is that, is that good, guys?
Are you entertained?
Copy, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure VeggieTales will not strike me down for the
off-tune, off-key, off-tempo rendition of VeggieTales.
Off lyrics.
VeggieTales could never copy strike me.
it's only something legally distinct veggie tails all right
well i can't do it i don't think i can for this one like
that's the closest oh yeah oh oh my god did you guys hear
thomas they're making an open world thomas the tank engine
game i'm sorry i i don't know where that came from i saw
that on twitter like an hour before the anniversary and i
was like oh my god i gotta tell my dragoons
Famous last words.
Guys, did you hear that?
That sounds so cool.
Yeah, they're planning on making an open world Thomas the
Tank Engine game.
It's coming soon.
Who asked for that?
I asked for it.
I want to be Thomas the Tank Engine.
what do you mean who asked for it I did oh my god and it's
gonna be made by the Pete devs who made train simulator oh
my god well it's gonna be my new what's it called my new
fanatic obsession thank you for the super chat thank you
You're Craton Berry.
You never had, you just found out about it.
Yes, I found out about it today, and then I asked for it.
I was like, oh my God, what, oh my God, I'm glad it's real.
Honestly, how can it be an open world?
The rails are right, the rails, the rails are like fixed.
How is that open world?
Yeah, open world, but you can only travel on the tracks.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
Any other requests, guys?
Any other special requests?
Do a flip.
Smug face.
My face is already smug.
Wait.
I mean, can I make it smug or it'd be like...
Come on.
I haven't done that in a long time.
It's been a while.
There we go.
There you go.
Yeah, that's pretty smug.
All right, back to my alleyway.
Where's my alleyway?
Oh, there it is.
Guys, I have so many scenes.
Back here.
Oh, yeah.
With Dad.
I love this background.
It's so, I don't know, it's so aesthetically pleasing.
I love looking at this background.
I think I'm just super nostalgic, too.
It really does remind me of, like, um, it really reminds me
of, like, the streets of hong kong like the local hong kong
uh markets and streets i
won't be playing this game for too long 70 hours later me
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you the
dragwood alley yeah i'm really happy with the neon chat
overlay like i had a little back and forth with the uh with
the coder um because like i i told him my inspiration was
like half cyberpunk Because, like, I don't know if you guys
noticed, but cyberpunk, the aesthetics and designs of
cyberpunk pulls heavily on, on, like, the streets of Hong
Kong and China with the whole neon lights.
If you ever seen, like, especially in China, there's, like,
if you ever seen, like, the cities in China, it really looks
like a cyberpunk.
It really looks very cyberpunk-ish, because that's where
they pull a lot of the design elements and the inspiration
from it from.
So I gave them a lot of references of the streets of Hong
Kong And Like the neon signs and stuff that you see when
you're walking around in Hong Kong or like in China
Yeah, the number of street signs and stuff Yeah, yeah,
because like a lot of a lot of the streets back there like
then or like still are Is like I have like neon signs and
stuff in the streets
yeah so when you super chat or when you like member um it
looks like a street side i don't know if you guys saw it i
don't know if someone wants to test it out but it's it's
really cool i love how like when someone super chats or like
if someone members it literally looks like a street side
but yeah like i'm just surprised i was able to like plan all
of this in a month and a half and
uh thankful for everyone i commissioned to be able to make
it in time with just a month and a half as a deadline
yeah see oh yeah look look at the super chats it's so cool
wait not yet not here oh no not here yet not well thank you
all for the gift that's just smoking they give it five gift
the ships they get that oh they're like look do you see it
oh it's god oh we're not five but it was there guys did you
guys caught it did you guys see it Yeah, it looks so cool.
I love it.
Huge shout out to the person who made the CSS code.
The chat code.
But I'll put up the credits again.
For those who haven't seen it yet.
My voice is dying.
It's been a very rough week, guys.
It's scary.
everyone i hope i got everyone hope i didn't miss anybody
but here's everybody that contributed to the anniversary
yeah so redo was the one that did the the coding for it i
felt really bad too because i was getting so many messages
uh i was getting a lot of messages as well um at the same
like like you know there's a lot of stuff going on so i felt
really bad because like um he was waiting for my reply on
like, oh, oh, like, uh, do you want this or this?
And then he was like, oh, I didn't work on it because I was
worried that you wouldn't like the result.
And I was like, oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
You have to remind me when you, if I don't respond in a day
or two, you have to poke me.
I literally get like 20 DMs every morning that's related to
work.
So I'm just like, I'm so sorry.
I'm so all over the place.
I'm so, but my name is Aki for the
you so much so i'm glad that he was able to he he fully he
finished the super chat design the design of the super chats
for the the code for it literally like this morning too like
he designed it and finished the code this morning because he
because he was like waiting for my approval on like um what
i want for the super chats but everything else was done it
was literally just the super chat part so like the fact that
he was able to make that in like what in less than a day
like it's crazy yeah like I said everything literally came
together this morning and then except for the background the
background was finished like a couple of like last week but
I do hope you guys like the reveal um I was really worried
about it like I said like um I've been doing this for a
while now um so it's always hard to figure out what to do
next.
That you know, it's always like, ah, how do I celebrate the
second year anniversary?
You know, I always like doing new things, you know.
I know a lot of people, they like to do, they like, they go
through the motions and stuff.
Like, it's very routine for them for anniversaries or
birthdays and stuff like that.
But for me, I love coming up with new ideas on celebrating
anniversaries or celebrating event, big events, like the
Unidocate and stuff, or like big, like you know birthdays
and stuff i always want to do new things and try new stuff
for it like you know um i've done a lot of things over the
years and even like you know like um you know my corporal
days i could just done redone stuff i did in corporal i
still want to have my own new touch to it a new spin to it
you know like how the doky line is very reminiscent of
something else i've done in the past with a 3d world but i
i've done like a new spin to it i made it bigger than it was
before made more had paid more attention to the detail of
the 3d world what i've learned in the past um and same here
for the anniversary i was like what can i do for the
anniversary i could just do a regular outfit reveal but i
love you know a lot of people for outfit reveals they just
reveal the outfit and then just that's it but i always love
being more creative in how i do outfit reveals too like a
little photo shoot not just like here's the feet and then
drag up i always i want to do something more creative and
how to showcase uh because like i feel like everyone knew
what the what the skin suit was gonna be anyway because it's
like very iconic you know alt doki is very retro alt doki is
very uh iconic already so like everyone sort of already
knows what it was gonna look like i still wanted to make it
really fun and um i want to be more creative of like how i
go into it i always like have a little story behind the
reveal like a little like session roleplay session and like
a little story behind like how we get into the reveal and
stuff like that like it's not just a regular reveal like we
have like a beginning middle and end to it like it's like
the purpose on what it is what what we're revealing and um
what's funny is that little photo shoot idea was supposed to
be something different I was supposed to do the reveal a
different way um but I had the photo shoot assets already
made uh um I've already had it already made for something
else and wanted it to be like uh I wanted it to like use it
for something else like I was thinking of like going to a
photo booth and getting photos taken and stuff but that was
like no this would be this would be like really fun if it
was to use as a as a skin suit reveal instead so that's I
pivoted to that like two days ago I pivoted to it and that's
why like today I actually asked Clea to draw on the like
hands and stuff onto the little check the little photos as
well to make it more like you know more immersive yeah two
days ago I was like oh wait this idea is better I feel like
I need more like it sucks because a lot of my like a lot of
my very creative ideas tend to come to me like last minute
I'd be like oh my god I can also do this and then like
literally like it would be like two to three days before I
have to do the reveal and then I just like I have like this
amazing creative idea and I'm like fuck okay okay we're
gonna see if I can make it work
Justin, thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, no, I work back.
I work really well under pressure, which is not ideal.
It is not ideal because I sometimes have these like really
cool ideas, but then like no time to like make it happen
just because like, you know, I don't want to like pressure
someone.
I if it's like something small to make, that's fine.
But like the fact that I had the ending, the end like how I
was like, oh, if only I could have the three animation of
like an actual ending to the store.
main it would have been easy but then I thought of that yeah
like two to three days ago and I was like there's not enough
time we have to get the 3D animation done first yeah
but what was I say Justin think of the Super Chat thank you
has it been two years already I remember the Mad Cat debut
I'm going to watch Tokyo's live and cheer with the last
stuff of my coffee thank you for the Super Chat thank you
thank you aka thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you um but yeah no i i really do appreciate it for all your
support and for you guys for uh enabling my fun creative
stupid ideas but always i don't have done this for so long
but i'm always still so nervous like i've done so many of
these events so many is adversaries and the birthday streams
and the big event my stone streams but every time i'm always
so fucking nervous going into it because you know you don't
know what's gonna happen when you're live you know anything
could happen like you know like what if like you mess up on
something like i'm always worried like oh why don't i mess
up on something like right now my head is not in the
streamer mindset it's not it's like it's half half it's like
i'm way too relaxed now i'm either actually no that doesn't
make sense i'm like stressed but relaxed at the same time
and they're fighting each other they're like stress because
of what's coming up next week relax because it's over now so
i'm i'm chill now like i'm like oh i i didn't my reveal and
everything now i just want to talk to my dragoons um but
then like my head is like so scrambled right now like i i'm
like it's so hard for me to formulate like like formulate
sentences and stuff yeah post stress perfectly balanced
the stress calmness cyber dragon thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you i'm looking forward to my um uh i am
looking forward to my vacation in march though i i'll be
taking like uh in march i'll be traveling and we'll be
taking like around a week a week break a week and a couple
of days break not a half apparently no week and a half maybe
um i don't know if i'll be streaming during like during that
vacation um like my manager actually rejected my sponsors
for march it was a lot of money too i was like no why did
you do that for those who weren't here on the twitch stream
um i talked about how um um basically i got offer two
sponsors during my vacation week and i was like you should
take it and then my manager would always like run it by me
and being like you want to take that sponsor or like like
they'll be like this is how much they're going to pay you
are you going to take that sponsor and i'll be like yes
usually like 99 of the chance i'd be like yes unless it's
like a game where i'm like oh i don't know um i don't know
if i can like make content with that but usually 99 of time
i would say yes anyway anyway i said yes and then like the
next day he was like i rejected your And I was like, what?
But why?
I had like, on this day and that day, I could have easily
streamed on my laptop in the hotel room.
And he was like, he's like, Doki, you need a vacation, man.
I was like, but it was so much money.
And he was like, Doki, you're barely functioning right now.
It's like, Doki, you had a nervous breakdown yesterday.
Like,
had a nervous breakdown yesterday because of overworked Doki
I think I think you you shouldn't you should use that
vacation to to actually relax I'm like but the money though
yeah I had a nervous breakdown but like but like I can just
cry about it and the money I earn
like but that's future Doki's problem not present Doki
problems um but anyway luckily my manager is much more
stable and uh yeah what I can wipe my tears with that bag
though manager I get but I could just wipe my tears with
that bag of money but anyway luckily my manager um is more
stable and what's the word more a sensible person is a is a
reasonable and is an adult luckily and know my limits and he
or she made sure that I did not have any sponsors or work
during my vacation you're green reasonable yeah yeah and
respond yeah like he's a much more responsible person
very rational exactly i don't know maybe i will sneak a
stream in who knows maybe i'll be like oh hey let's talk
about what i was doing on my vacation or maybe i show some
that like show you guys what i did Well, not really, because
then they'll be like, no, actually, I shouldn't do that.
Like, I should do that after I leave the country.
Yes, I will be traveling overseas, but I was like thinking,
yeah, maybe I should do that after I leave the country.
Don't.
Yeah.
Work-life.
What balance?
There's no work-life balance.
It's just work.
It's just work and work.
Doki cries and mighty raging Thank you for the super chat
Thank you, thank you
Sorry my nose is stuffy Snuffier Stuffier right now There's
no snuffier It says no raccoons allowed in Dragoon Alley By
Doki Bird Association Law
Yeah, it's work and Marvel rivals balance work o'clock oh
someone asked like about the upgraded assets that was my
original assets before i started wearing uh sports bra it
was it was my original it this is what it's always was like
i'm just not wearing a sports bra right now guys i'm freeing
the goods you gotta let them breathe sometime you know you
know i found out if you if okay for those uh for the for the
men out there for those who don't know um apparently
actually i don't know actually i don't know might be
spreading misinformation but you have to have a balance
between wearing your bras because if you wear your bras too
much you're destroying the elasticity of your of your bobs
but then if you don't wear your bras enough then gravity
does its work a little fun fact a little so you have to have
a good like balance between like bra or no bra the goods
yeah they sell sports bras for thighs yes they do That's
what the belts are for Thank you, the super chat Thank you,
thank you
They need support Yes, but if you support it too much Then
like Then it'll be like They'll like think They'll have It's
like if you use your training reels too much You're going to
rely on it The entire time They gotta build the strength
They gotta be able to support itself sometimes But then if
it supports itself too much If you're independent too much,
then gravity comes for us all.
It works for the boss down there, too.
For the men out there, you can't escape gravity as well.
Just remember, you can't escape gravity, too.
No one escapes gravity.
you?
What are you saying?
I learned that on Twitter.
I didn't realize that.
I was like, wait, that also happens?
Thank you, Twitter algorithm.
Chat, is this real?
Oh, no one escapes gravity.
No.
You see, the difference is that we have bras.
Not even.
Oh, my God.
Wait, that reminded me.
It's about the Olympics.
But did you guys hear there's a new meta in skiing?
Oh, my God.
So, like, apparently, chat.
So good.
That chat is this real.
Oh yeah, but like, okay, there's a new meta in Olympic
skiing.
So apparently the new controversy in the Olympics is that
they had to implement a new rule in Olympic skiing because
skiers were injecting acid into their PPs so that they would
expand more.
so that when they get fitted for their ski uniform, they
would get, like, extra material.
So after the acid wears off, they get, like, um, they get,
like, an X amount of extra material, and it makes it more
aerodynamic.
What?
Yeah!
So, like, the Olympics had to make a statement yesterday,
being like, we have now issued a new rule regarding ski
jumping.
You're now not allowed.
to shoot up acid in your dicks so that you can get more
material for your uniform what the actual like I did not
need this knowledge so like so so the skiers can have more
aerodynamic for their ski jumps sport meta go crazy I truly
is crazy I'm not sure I understood any of those words in
that order who the hell who the hell who the hell injected
acid in their peepee to find out who just just use Viagra
white acid this is what you talk about in your second year
is how I spend my holidays someone's back check this but
even if you won the gold it's not worth it maybe it's
because there's already oh honestly i think the reason why
they didn't use biagra is because there's already a rule in
ski jumping about it so then the guy was like well they said
nothing about shooting acid in your peepee they found the
loophole they're like Well, they said nothing about acid,
though.
Like, Jesus.
Your daily dose of cursed knowledge from Tokey Bird.
Bro, it was literally yesterday's news.
It was like everywhere on my Twitter algorithm.
People were like, how did people come up with all these
loopholes for the Olympics?
every olympic they come up with a new rule because people
find new ways to cheat in the olympics it's crazy actual
rules like bro i don't fucking know of at least i just i
don't know there's no rules that says dogs can't play
basketball guys
I heard See it Look, it's because the Olympics started
yesterday I get Oh my god, the Olympics started yesterday It
was a day one ban It was a The fact that It was a day one
ban Ain't so smart How can't believe he got caught On day
one That's unfortunate Literally the Olympics started it
yesterday oh here i'll show you guys the tweet
here here guys this is i bookmarked it i was like this is a
fun fact i gotta i gotta share it to the class that's that's
like a bad excuse to why they have acid in the first place
krish thank you for the super chat thank you thank you bro
ski Jumping is a very serious sport, guys.
It's a fun fact.
Oh, it's such a fun fact.
Oh, my God.
Did you guys know there's Jeff Boo-Boo's now?
Here.
Guys, they came out with Jeff Boo-Boo's.
The little Boo-Boo's arrivals.
Yeah, of course I bookmarked it.
I was like, I gotta share.
I gotta share the knowledge.
Sharing is caring, guys.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
okay these are like a lot of stuff I wanted to talk about
that I forgot about but like do you guys hear about the new
character what's her name uh new phoenix of overwatch uh
onran onron or something and then someone did like uh
there's a new character they shadow dropped five characters
in overwatch um and one of her name one of them is her name
is onron and she's literally like a copy of phoenix um
because her alt is literally her alt is literally phoenix
and I thought it was so like the funny thing is unrelated to
any of her abilities it's the fact that like she just looks
like Juno and Kiriko and someone was like how did she get
like plastic surgery or something cuz what the fuck happened
to her face and like someone did like a comparison of like
of like the model like expectations and reality Wait, let
me, I'll show it to you.
I was like, what the fuck?
They, like, shaved off her nose.
What happened to her nose?
Where did it all go?
Did she get plastic surgery before she joined Overwatch?
That's crazy.
I was like, what the fuck?
Here, look at that.
This is not the same person.
Like, great fucking.
Who is this?
like yeah
and then there was a gif of like her someone like putting
different types of hair
she literally got plastic surgery before she joined
overwatch
that was crazy i i mean like gotta sell skins i guess like i
like when they put galacta on their next yeah in the galacta
area it and then the fucking toward the ball toward born got
your nose i mean to be fair to be fair like okay the only
issue is that she's not support though like that's the thing
look i feel like okay so for tps these are the tps
characters are it would be like ash and widow the most
played dps characters um that uh people buy skins for ash
widow and junk rat because like junk rat like there's a very
dedicated one trick community for junk rat but like i don't
think on onran is gonna have a very dedicated community of
dps players that's gonna play onran it would make more sense
if they're gonna make a copy they're gonna make a copy of
kiriko and juno it should be a support then because because
like because i feel like she would have sold much more skins
if she was a support player if she was a support character
versus a dps character because people who pick like pick the
female dps characters are not like the baby face characters
they're like the the like oh she's so hot her looks could
kill me type shit she's like you know they're like you know
like like ash like ash and widow they're like oh yeah
they're the bad girls like i want to play her they're the
bad girl dps characters yeah you know and then and like aran
does not look like a bad bitch she does not look like she
she looks like she looks like um she looks like this her
first day at school
yeah I love a woman that would just kill me yeah she looks
like I need to hold her hand and tell her where the point is
and be like that's the point Arran please please go there
so I feel like a lot of people I feel like a lot of I feel
like she won't have as many people buying her skins compared
to like like the other characters next see they give the
super chat thank you thank you does this mean alt girl doki
is a support to bounty hunter doki's dps i think i can
actually make a 6v6 hero shooter game out of doki's um alt
doki would be support um dokefield will be tank
will be DPS.
Alright, who would be the other support character?
Who would...
You see the vision?
Yes, you see the vision.
Oh!
Almost forgot.
I got another surprise for you guys.
There were so many things I gotta show you.
I had so many things to show you guys.
I almost forgot about this.
Alright, give me a sec.
it just reminded me while we were listing all there's while
we were listing all the dokees it made me remember something
while we were talking about all the dokees
uh wait uh oops all
right you guys ready You guys ready for For that For another
special surprise
What is it?
Say please I need to see I need to see like The want And the
excitement for it I need to say passion Where is a passion
are you guys ready he
was a skater boy she said see you later boy
Oh wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, yeah, skater parade, it's
done, it was done a while ago, but I figured the first best
time to show you guys skaterbird um because because we
released a new avro like released the avro levine cover so i
was like this is the perfect time this is the perfect time
for
skaterbird she was he was a boy she was a girl can i make it
any more obvious that's one i think like skaterboy uh
skaterboy was my it's my favorite Avril Levine song.
Did you know she's really popular in Japan?
She has like really she has a really dedicated fan base in
Japan and that's why she released the song Hello Kitty.
Apparently Hello Kitty is like super popular in Japan
because she has like a huge fan base over there and she
released that song dedicated to her Japanese fans.
I did not realize, I did not know that.
I did not realize she was like super popular over there.
It's her and who else is it?
There's like Her and Carly Ray Jepson are really, really
popular in Japan.
Wait, he was a boy.
She was a girl.
Can I make it any more obvious?
He was a punk.
She did ballet.
What more can I say?
He wanted her.
She never tell.
Secretly, she wanted him as well.
But all of her friends stuck up their nose and they had a
problem with him.
baggy clothes he was a skater boy she said see you later boy
she wasn't good enough for her she had a pretty face but her
head was up in space she needed to come back down on earth
yeah oh yeah oh yeah by the way i have stuff here too um
wait what can i show you look i have i have my safety helmet
guys remember to wear your hat don't worry guys before i
escape i got my safety helmet i got my helmet to make sure
to make sure i don't go into a coma yeah
i don't know i love this i love that design
it's so cute yeah welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome
there's so many dokees now i need to make a new thread of
all the dokees in the dokeverse like a compilation uh for
the schedule stuff you know like when i tweet out like here
are the outfits and everything i'm gonna make a compilation
of of all oh yeah like little stickers on my helmet too my
little safety helmet my special helmet my mom makes me wear
it everywhere i go even when i'm not skating
safety is so cool exactly it's so cool it's like those like
it's like those um back in the 90s where they made like tv
shows about like don't do drugs kids like and then and then
fucking um who is it the teenage mutant ninja trail is like
drugs are not cool cow bunga dude
That's sleepy.
They give it a five gift and ships.
They give thank you.
I'm very special.
And then.
Oh yeah.
Gun.
Yeah.
The PS8 culture.
That's right.
I also have a gun.
Cowabunga dude.
Stay in school, kids.
Wear your helmet.
Because not wearing your helmet is not rad.
It's not radical, bro.
Yo, what the fuck?
That's right.
Now that's safety.
It's not very...
It's okay.
on so it's very safe now get down oh yeah spin it like also
a lot yeah dude
gnarly bro oh my god also how the fuck is gnarly a song I
recently discovered the song gnarly because it was on the
Grammys or whatever and literally I was like how did so many
people Listen to this song.
He's like Fobati gnarly chicken fried chicken gnarly What
the fuck are the lyrics?
Tesla gnarly
I can't believe that's a real song The beat the beats are
fire, but like who the fuck wrote those songs?
lyrics i think the fact that it was like boba teeth nah like
it's start this is how that's how the song starts for those
who've never listened to it have you ever listened to like
the was it touch me uh from cat's eye um which is a very
nice song it's a very good song it's like uh i forgot i was
like um it has a very catchy tune and just suddenly it's
like boom and then they went to And it was like, Foba tea,
gnarly, Tesla, gnarly, fried chicken, gnarly.
Fried chicken, gnarly.
It's like the first three lines, fried chicken, gnarly.
The dad says, the Corey.
Like, I was in Praetorium beats are good, but holy fuck,
what the fuck is that lyric?
Oh, yeah, gang gang.
But they're like, yeah, gang gang.
I'm not watching that.
Good.
I, I envy you.
I wish I was, I, I wish I was this ignorant of the world.
well i wish i'd never discover gnarly i wish i get to live
life oblivious of the existence of that song gnarly is like
a g6 of our generation i hate it i'm making that fewer
well-done covers instead make ones of actual good song i'm
not crap fine we're so thank you the super chat thank you oh
my god wait geez oh my god wait g6 i just that's a blast
from the past like a g6
G6 was better No, no, you cannot compare G6 to gnarly Like a
G6 Like, bong Like a g6 Like, it has an actual tune Bam,
bong, bong, bong Till I fly like a g6 Like a g6 Like, she's
actually singing She didn't say Fried chicken gnarly
g6 was a real banger the song didn't start out talking about
boba tea and fried chicken
i think my where the fuck did i put my mouse you oh there it
is my mouse you wispy
all right wait all right let me swap back gotta swap back
But yeah, skater bird is real now.
It was
made by accident?
How so?
How is it made by accident?
My manager told me he was going to go to sleep, and then I
see him still awake.
Liar!
I see you I see you're still on your PC Oh yeah I was gonna
tell you guys about Iron Lung I watched Iron Lung Because I
found out that it was going to be Around for a week Also
before I talk about Iron Lung My merch is out My second year
anniversary Buy my merch The website is pinned in my chat
But it's jokimurch.com But yeah, check out my merch.
Check out my new second year anniversary merch.
And also my new cover, my new music cover.
Girlfriend.
Anyway, before I...
Um...
Um, I...
I checked out...
I finally checked out Iron Lung.
For...
Um...
Because I...
You know, the Markiplier movie.
By the way, for those who don't know.
Um, I finally checked out the new Markiplier movie.
Because, you know...
I want to know...
I wanted to know if the movie, because like, you know, use
critics didn't like it, but users love it.
But then also, like, user reviews tend to be more so of
Markiplier fans, you know?
So I just wanted to see, like, what's it all about?
And the movie apparently was only going to be in theaters
for one week, apparently.
And I managed to check it out.
And I will say, I think it's okay.
think it's okay.
Markiplier is surprisingly a pretty good actor.
He is like he is surprisingly pretty good actor.
And it all really takes place in one location, like
literally like in that submarine thing.
And I think like I feel like my only issue with the movie is
that there's a lot of like the hints about his backstory.
Like the ending was very confusing.
um but like they hint about like how he because he's like a
convict or whatever he's like a prisoner that was sent into
the submarine but they're never like super clear on why he
was a prisoner in the first place you get like little tiny
hints or whatever but it's so confusing it's really really
confusing and apparently um apparently i was reading like
the reddit and the wiki about like what the fuck was going
on I was like, I was, I literally, after the movie, I was
like, Iron Lung ending explain.
I literally went to Google.
I was like, Iron Lung explain.
Like, because I was like, there was like some parts where I
was very confused.
And, and there was a summary of it being that explained that
if you have gain knowledge, you'll understand more so of why
he was a prisoner because the game explains it like the game
lore explains why he was a prisoner and stuff so apparently
there's like a political um there was like a political fight
between two uh two governing bodies and he was part of the
governing body that lost basically so and uh he was a
political he was basically a political prisoner and so I was
like okay that makes a lot more sense now like what he did
as like what he did to get became a prisoner and like the
game explains it and the guy was explaining it and
everything I was like oh that makes more sense but it's very
vague it's very vague in the movie itself on why he was a
prisoner and stuff but like I wouldn't mind it but they kept
trying to explain it in the movie but it was so confusing
because it didn't make much more sense like because it was
like it felt like It was like five to 10 second scenes of
like, like trauma memories from him.
He would have like trauma memories that would show up for
like five to 10 seconds, but it made no sense to me on what
the fuck he's trying to remember.
I was like, yeah, yeah.
So like, and so, so like that was the confusing part.
The ending was also a little confusing too.
confusing because it was like it was like i was like i like
the ending there was a part where he he he like starts
deteriorating his body starts deteriorating and um and then
i didn't i and then there was like a lot of voices basically
it was like what do the voices say because there was a lot
of voices going on in the ending and every apparently some
of the voices are giving like really good plot points of
what the fuck was going on and then and then but there were
so many voices it was like you know when like I was playing
that voice too and it was like Santa's not real
and and like but like half of those voices are trying to
give you like important information yeah but but like that's
what's like super confusing for me at one point but i it was
just be like some scenes are yeah it's like the ending has a
very confusing point there but like you know the end result
it's like oh okay but then like the ending scene gets very
confusing at one point um cooler thank you the super chat
thank you thank you yo skaterbird happy tokyversary love
your throwback outfit also tomorrow's my birthday can you
throw me a great to thank you thank you for the super
chatting thank you and have a future happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear cooler happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday yeah
but yeah other than that it's like it was a good movie um it
was just i will say it wasn't my type of movie because it's
a very slow burn if you like slow burn and that's I it took
a while to get there the first hour is like basically like
nothing is really going on and the first it's a two hour
movie and the first hour there's really nothing to go on but
like each but even though it's one hour like even though
there's like nothing really going on in that hour like
little bits and pieces are foreshadowing the rest of the
movie like i i swear to god i wanted to look at my phone in
that first hour right yeah it's a very slow start but when
it ramps up it goes hard and like fucking gas gas gas into
like lots of shit is happening after the first hour um but
like that first hour was a hurdle for me because i'm not
very good at i'm not very good at slow burn i i'm i'm not
very good at slow burn so so the first hour was a big hurdle
but after the hour is gone like it fucking goes hard but
that's my that's my honest opinion on iron line
yeah i need my fortnite skins in that movie i need my subway
surfers but yeah no i i think he did really well for um as
like a you know as an indie movie project.
That's all.
The fact that he wrote that movie himself was very
impressive.
I did not realize he wrote it himself too.
I did not realize he was a writer.
He's very talented.
Being able to write, direct, and produce a movie all on his
own.
And act in it too.
Usually, like, you know, usually we just hire a writer, but
he wrote it himself.
So I was, like, really impressed with that.
Okay.
Yeah.
He funded himself too, yeah.
Joki movie went fucking...
3D first.
And 3D debut first.
And...
One day.
I had to delay the 3D debut only because, like I said, I
didn't have time to travel.
No time to travel last year.
the last half year no time to travel at all too many
obligations
i think that's why it's definitely harder as an indie i know
some people were like oh man streaming is so easy but it
also depends on what you want to do as a streamer too um i
want to do a lot of things so that like i don't just like
sit there i want to do like a lot of fun fun things for you
guys like a lot of like variety stuff and um and like and
like do a lot of projects and everything and because of that
like i have to like manage i'm so bad at time management i'm
so fucking bad i have so little time so many projects
gen gen x thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you hey
doki you can't stick around for the stream today but just
want to pop in and say Congrats on two years, thank you!
Here's hoping for more fun years to come.
Thank you, the Akasupa.
And thank you for just dropping by.
And for the Akasupa, it really does mean a lot.
I really appreciate the support.
Thank you.
But, like, I'm worried one day I'm just going to run out of
ideas.
That's what I'm most worried about.
Because, like, I have some fun ideas for my birthday.
I know what to do for my birthday.
I know what to do for my next outfit reveal.
but it's like what about next year like i'm like i'm running
out of ideas that's my biggest worry i always tell myself
though when i hit a million i will i would like calm down i
would like calm down more because that was my that's my
biggest goal i think after a million i'm like i like that's
why i'm like i made it and i disappeared no i'm joking i'm
I'm joking, I'm just, please, please don't subscribe, I
won't disappear, I, I'm, I'm joking, I'll come back, I'll
still be here, yeah, please, don't, you already made it,
yeah, but it's like, a million is when you're like, oh my
gosh, I made it, made it, you know, you get a little golden
button, you know, it's, it's like the silver button, but
it's yellow and it's like me color basically unsubbing it's
like it's me color that's
why you hire a creative team you know i love being like
hands i do delegate but i also love being hands on because i
feel like my ideas like the things i want to do and my ideas
are like i feel like some of the things i think of like are
not are things that like a creative team wouldn't think of
themselves type deal things i want to do and like i like
having like a lot of creative input on how stuff like on how
things are done but like you know like i mean for the
tournament i'm like not that hands-on to be fair i do did
give suggestions for it um you know for the PUBG tournament
I like because it's like under my name I gave a lot of like
guidance on tournament structure and stuff and how like how
the tournament should be run because originally they wanted
rehearsals they wanted rehearsals for the tournament and I
straight up told them I was like you are not getting these
streamers together at the same day at the same time to show
up for these rehearsals I'm sorry like It's like, that is a
very impossible ask that you're trying to get.
Like, I was like, I was like, you're not coordinating.
You're not coordinating four teams of five to all show up on
the same day, at the same time to do a rehearsal.
That is like unfeasible.
Like, it might work.
it might i honestly think like because like it's um pubg for
those who don't know is um i assume wait let me double check
like the company it's a production team is uh the production
team uh is uh crafton which is a south korean um video game
publishing i'll assume that like i know like in asia a lot
of tournaments do rehearsals too uh or like scrims like you
know in asia scrims and rehearsals for tournaments it's
quite common but you'd be lucky if NA pro teams even show up
for scrims.
You'd be lucky if professional players who are professional
at their chosen games even show up to like practice an NA.
So, I was like, yeah, like we have to, like I was straight
up told them like you have to get rid of rehearsals
yeah i would be like you can get half the team like maybe
like half the participants not even half the team not even
like the full roster of each team but more so of like maybe
like two to three of the players and one team will show up
no seriously and it is just do it on game day we just show
up Sleepy.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I'm going to join Jen with leaving at work in the morning.
Avriola Doki was one little thing and hope the money is sent
will help fund future projects.
Lastly, to those who I saw in chat, thank you for the
membership.
Don't mention it.
Happy Dokiversary.
Thank you, the Akasupa.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much for the support.
I hope you have a good day at work in the morning tomorrow.
But thank you for giving up your time to watch me and for
the support.
I really appreciate it.
Even though, even so if it was a practice, I do not think I
like straight up was like, I think it's like incredibly hard
to coordinate as someone that has seen the, as someone that
has, that knows the NA scene and like how busy streamers are
in general.
Like I know like, like especially like how busy like content
creators and streamers are in general.
It's very hard to coordinate like how many people are
participating?
Five, 10, 15, 20, I guess like 20 people all at once.
to come together like Giro thank you for the Aka Aka Aka
Supa!
Thank you!
Happy anniversary to my Kamioshi at work tonight but I just
want to thank you for making me and so many other smiles to
many more years to come I should say stay very strong and
stay smiling again!
Thank you for the Aka Aka Aka Supa!
Thank you for the support!
I would have a good day at work tonight but thank you again
I really appreciate it guys.
Thank you so for giving up your time um hanging out with me
and to celebrate donkey day two years two years um but yeah
and what else what else did i say i like gave several oh
yeah and then i said don't do it on valentine's day because
i was like um i was like a lot of content creators also
stream on valentine's day and i feel like especially like
vtube reviewers don't want to watch might not because like
they said they wanted to invite like vtubers as well um so
like lily peachy's team was like uh the vtuber team and i
advised i also said like other than the fact that i was like
my dog's birthday is on valentine's day so like i personally
would not want it on valentine's day because i always
celebrate dad's birthday on valentine's day but i also said
that a lot of streamers tend to tend to stream on
valentine's day as well um so i was just like i think people
I think the streamers, whichever streamer you would invite,
whatever streamer you would invite, they would prefer, like,
doing a regular stream than a tournament stream.
So I, like, gave that advice, too.
And also the fact that I straight up said, like, I need to
celebrate my dog's birthday.
Like, it's tradition.
It's tradition.
I chose my dog over a tournament.
That's right.
I chose my dog.
and also like, then they were like, what about the 12th and
13th, and I know like Min's concert was on the 13th, and I
know a lot of you guys are also heading towards Min's
concert or like going to watch the stream, so I was like, I
guess like I felt like, oh since I felt like we should keep
the 13th, like we shouldn't have 13th as well because of
that, and I was like just put it on the 15th and 16th, this
feels like the best.
yeah yeah so like there's like pieces of advice i gave them
regarding like how like i even like gave tips regarding
algorithm too because like uh twit like like you know that's
what i'm saying like um i like to be more i like i like
being hands-on with some projects and stuff or like having
input on them because i i've done this for a long time i've
done it for a long time so i sort of like know like what you
should do and what you shouldn't do for these types of
things and then i even told them like when i found out about
lily peachy's team i straight up i straight up the first
thing i said when i was like what because i was the last
person to have a finalized team um because it was very like
because like timing and like a lot of my friends are really
busy on that day um and that someone dropped out as well so
i was the last person to finalize my entire team roster but
and and then like i was told lily peachy's team ashtray up
told them when they told me their team i was like you have
to tell them like what kind of tournament this is like like
that like the skilled level of this tournament because i
would feel bad you know i would feel really bad because what
if they got in being like being like oh it's um it's very
like super casual and then I found out the rosters of the
other two teams and I was like okay like these guys are
sweaty so then I was like you have to tell the Pichu team
like the skill level of this tournament and like what the
expectation will be like going in so they're not you know
they're not like oh my god what the fuck yeah you know you
know I didn't want them to go in like blindsided you know
and because like i've had so many experiences in especially
like in twitch rivals where i was told like it'll be a
casual thing don't worry and then i'd be like the like you
said remember i don't know if you guys remember the
fortnight tournament i was invited to i was invited to where
i was told i'd be like don't worry it'll be a casual
fortnight event and i was like oh that's fine and i find i
was the only person that wasn't a fortnight player that was
invited to
and I was like what the fuck guys
so like so I didn't want them like because I've had
experiences like that where I would get into a tournament
and realize wait this was a lot sweatier than what I assumed
at first and then so I was like you have to tell her like
when I found out I was like you gotta let her know because I
don't want her to be like, what the fuck going in?
Yeah, I was, I needed a plus one.
Yeah.
They're like, tell her it's casual, but she'll say yes to
anything, and they were right.
They were right.
I did.
Even the party animals.
Oh my god.
Remember the party animals, Twitch rivals?
I was like, oh, it's a party game.
It should be casual.
find out going in i found out that there were like people
hardcore grinding party animals for like 10 plus hours
before twitch rivals like before the tournament started and
they had like knew all the meta and all the fucking like all
the meta and like the the tech for party animals and i was
like what i thought this was a party game i they knew like
what the matter like what all the game modes are like like
like even party games weren't safe
guys yeah it was crazy that's why i was like straight up
like like you know from the experiences I've built up over
from the experiences I've built up over the years like my I
share my wisdom to others I share it with others so
that we won't repeat the same mistake again
yeah I played these games before I have to break the cycle
yeah I want to say it again guys thank you all I can't
believe it oh my gosh it's been like almost four hours I
want to say thank you all for me here I can't believe I
spent two years since I returned some of you guys have
followed me for maybe longer than two years maybe three
years four five six seven wait how long have I been
streaming for wait actually I know I have some that were
actually Do I have OG bark knights here right now Actually
Where are my OG bark knights The OGs I know you guys been in
here for I've lost count I've actually forgotten How long
we've been here Eight years Oh my god Is it really?
I know I like I know I have a Twitch clip That was six years
ago I don't know if it was seven or eight years When I
started like being more serious About V-Tubing
It was either seven or eight I don't remember
But like But like Oh eight years here Holy fuck I've been
doing this for eight years Oh my God.
How do I, I'm, oh my God.
That's, that's insane to think about in my head that I've
been doing this for eight years.
Now it does not feel like eight years.
No wonder I look like this.
This is how it looks like after eight years.
This is me like, this was like, this is like four years and
then this is eight years.
But I have to let you guys remember, um, the first three to
four years of that streaming career I think it was like
three years for the first three to four years of that
streaming career I basically had no streaming career like I
never got partnered um when I was in indie before I know I'm
indie now but um before corporal I was never partnered I got
rejected three times for partnering by the way three times
for partner um to be fair the last two attempts was me said
i sent the b movie script to be fair for those who want like
laura uh the first time i sent in a real application the
second and third time um i don't remember what i sent for
the third time but the second time i sent in the b movie
script because i was like do they even read this uh and then
the third time i don't even remember what i think i also i
sent uh i sent the i sent something but i don't remember
what script it was I don't I just I just stop caring because
at that time when I sent in the third partner application I
already got in I got my acceptance letter so then I was like
whatever like because I was like fuck that I'm like you
going corporal baby like so then I was just like I don't
fucking care
I don't care.
I'm piecing out.
And then, and then I, you know, I came back.
and I was like, and then I was, cause like, I have the third
attempt.
I was like, who cares?
I don't need this no more.
Um, anyway, um, but like I said, like, I never really made
it at first when I was, when I was first in indie because I
never, um, I didn't, okay, to be fair, when I was first in
Indie, uh, eight years ago, like, my first three years of
YouTubing eight years ago, I didn't talk to anybody.
Like, I talked to people, but I, but it was more so of like
Twitter mutuals, stuff like that.
Like, I was raw.
I still came back and I keep crawling back.
Anyway, um, um, so, um, So when I actually got serious about
it, I never really like interacted with other VTubers or
like, you know, I never really tried talking to anybody.
I do have, I did have like Twitter mutuals and they were
mostly like art friends.
So, you know, like, you know, I talked to like a lot of
artists back then because I was an artist back then as well.
So I commissioned a lot of art.
I also like, I loved interacting with a lot of like artists
and stuff and just, you know, talk to have a lot of artists
friends.
back then and but i never really like collab with people i
never really collab with people i never really like try the
social climb or anything or like increase my network i never
networked at all i was mostly a solo streamer who or who
would play with my rank buddies who aren't really streamers
but they were just really good at apex or some shit or
really good at overwatch but they weren't interact with a
lot of overwatch streamers back then but i never streamed
when i never really streamed when i was bumping into like
overwatch streamers um so um it was only when later on it
was only i only started networking when i was in corpo
because i knew like i had to actually interact with people
when i like i was like i'm gonna be a new person i'm gonna
actually be social and interact with people and make new
friends i'm not gonna be a show social out like my indie
days I'm gonna interact with a lot of people because I knew
like that's what you have to do when you're like in the
corporal like that's how you like build yourself up um um
because it was like my golden ticket so I was just like oh I
shouldn't I should make sure like you know I should take
advantage of what they gave me so uh yeah I was like I
should take advantage of what i they gave me and what um
what um of this golden opportunity because it wasn't like
you know it was like uh you know i wanted to like hit the
hit the wall running type deal and yeah make the most of
everything yeah and then that's when i started interacting
with a lot of people when i hit the when i was in the
company and then after i came back as an indie i have i have
trust issues now
interact with a lot of people but then I'm so tired and yeah
and then I was just like I was like um after that I was just
like I just want to be in my little in my little circle and
I interacted yeah I was like too I was tired from
interacting with a lot of people and and yeah I was like
this I was like
um and i i i do want to interact with people more it's just
i'm i it's like baby steps you know i it's like baby steps i
don't want to like be like have like a uh stretch myself too
thin type feel i wanted to like you know meet new people and
uh get to know them more like one by one like little like
little baby steps versus like you know just be like you want
to collab fuck it let's run it like because that's what I
did in the past I was just like hey you want to collab next
week let's go now I'm just like give me four to five
business days I not even give me seven to ten business days
I'll get back to you soon
Like, I never thought I could ever actually have this as a
career, not gonna lie.
Like I said, I, when I first started streaming, like, I was
fucking, I was a nobody.
Also, I did not care about, like, schedules or whatever.
I fucking, I did not care about being consistent.
I didn't care about, like, schedules.
I didn't care about variety.
I was like, I'm going to play Apex for 20 hours.
And you're gonna watch that I mean, well not really people
didn't really watch me I'm just like if someone shows up
that's pretty cool like I was like I'm gonna stream apex now
for 13 plus hours in rank and then like if some like someone
talks in my chat That's pretty cool and then after and then
I keep doing consistently I'll do it consistently and then I
would have like I would have like a 20 plus view 20 to 30
viewer average and I was like This is, I'm actually getting
an audience now.
This is getting too real.
All right, guys, I'm going to disappear for five months.
I was like, wow, I'm actually starting to build a community.
All right, guys, peace.
I'm going to leave now.
I'm going to grind off stream for five plus months.
I guess I'll see you guys when I see you.
And this will happen a lot.
This will happen a lot.
If anyone's a Bark Night, they will remember all the hiatus.
as I've taken over the years.
Yeah, the self-sabotage was very real.
Oh, wow.
I'm actually sort of getting successful now.
I better stop.
No, it was legit.
I was sometimes they would be lucky if I even tell them when
I'm coming back.
Sometimes it just stops and then it just stops.
And then suddenly I would just go live and be like, I guess
I'm back, guys.
Hey.
because like i just be like all right yes i'm here
so so like my bark nights were very very very supportive and
very uh like persevered they were what's the word they were
um they believed in me and i'm really thankful for that like
they really believed in me as a streamer because um i was
not a very i was not a very consistent streamer and we're
very loyal uh they're very resilient resilient and
everything they were starving they were like i'm so hungry
don't keep please i haven't eaten in seven months so it's
crazy to think about um it's crazy to think about that i've
made it this far and i have so many of you guys still
watching me to this day still supporting me via like even
just watching me like super chatting clipping me um buying
my merch um um talking about me on like to your friends or
like talking about me on twitter like every little bit like
helps grow my community my channel and it really does help
out a lot like little thing builds up into like you know it
all builds up together and i really appreciated dragons
especially for how so many years too you guys have been here
for me um like you know dragons come and go but we all still
have like the memories of our times together and the
memories we made together as a community you know and like
the funny moments like i like that i always try include you
guys into this funny, funny streams and funny moments and
try to be interactive with all of you guys.
Because you're all part of me.
You're all part of Dokeybird.
You're all part of the community.
You can't be Dokeybird without the dragons or the bark
knights.
And I really appreciate it.
So thank you guys for sticking with me for this, Yad.
And I hope that we are Dokeybird.
Dicks out for Dokeybird.
Wait, actually, no, don't.
scratch that sorry i was thinking about harambe that's not
what i mean out of context do not do that do not do excuse
me no no no dude do not do that i was thinking about harambe
and i realized that this does not i realized it i realized
that it is two different things it doesn't work
It was a little, a little oopsie.
I forgot I'm not Harambe.
We are, but we'll keep, we are Doki Bird.
We are Doki Bird is good.
Free airport.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
You.
It's too late.
Get out of context, Doki.
So we are.
We are Doki Bird.
But yeah, like I said, sorry, I ruined the moment.
It was such a heartfelt moment.
And then I had to say it.
I let my Harambe out.
After Doki doing that, that's our O.C.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Bird.
And that's actually on the press.
Anyway, as I was saying, SF, welcome to the main farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Thank you all for the huge support.
I'm going to call it here, guys.
Thank you for celebrating my two-year...
anniversary with me i hope you guys enjoyed the show i guys
enjoyed today's stream and had a fun time with me today uh
with all the little funny skits the little role play that we
did the concert the cover music video the reveals the merch
um i hope you guys like the merch too like i said my the me
my manager and the distributor worked really hard um getting
all of it together um you know a merch that you guys would
want and not and not what i want i i want this too okay what
we both want the dog shit was just a me thing but like this
time i'm pretty sure dragoons and me want this merch like
i'm pretty sure this time i like i figured it out i'm i
think we're on the same wavelength this time chat but i
think i'm most excited about is the mini dokees i think are
so fucking cute oh my god i'm really i think oh my i'm
looking forward to uh seeing all the pictures of you guys
taking the mini dokeys out of this and also the the capes
too ah i love that i love that we could make the capes oh my
god i've been wanting to do this too the little dragon capes
a little dragon army you can have and a little dad's too you
can have one one mini dokey wearing a dad wearing the dad
pawn chip the dad cape and the other one with the dragon and
then the other one with nothing she's naked not like dokey
prime though um yeah i'm i'm super excited they look so it's
like you know we're not the sampling isn't even done yet um
the drafts aren't even done yet and you can and you can
throw it against the wall too if you really want to um it's
very throwable unfortunately i don't think dokey prime dokey
prime will uh cease to exist we have she has been snapped
out of existence all we have now is just a photo of her uh
she didn't she didn't make it guys i'm sorry all we have is
just a photo you only met her like two hours ago what do you
mean you miss her you only found out about her two
but I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream thank you for all
the artwork too the artwork um the clips I saw some artwork
already in the clips and um all the stuff that you guys made
the fan writers the editors the the fans all the fans thank
you guys like I said they're quarter feet a dokeybird
without the dragons and um you guys are what keep me going
and what are the reason why I'm able to do all these cool
things be able to do all these cool projects make uh
reinvest in my channel and you I always want to reinvest in
the channel and in you guys and um your support keeps me
going so I hope we can see each other again next year as
well and the years to come I don't know what I'm gonna do
for my third year but like I had a great second year
anniversary out wait that was it was a great dokey day we
had a great dokey day guys um and
and dokey day is technically not just a celebration of me in
this channel but a celebration of you guys like you guys
make this happen and you guys supported this little bird who
thought she wouldn't make it because i would always
self-sabotage myself uh the first three to four years i
didn't think i would actually be a streamer and now look at
me i'm here now this is like my job now so thank you
everybody uh thank you for coming to toky day and as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flow and you stay up for me head to bed
cause you deserve it thank you for always believing in me
guys and thank you for always watching me and giving your
time to to even be here oh my god time is valuable and you
you spent your time with me and that really means a lot i
spent my time with you hanging out with you guys and you
spent your time hanging out with me so thank you guys all
right i'll see you guys next time everybody oh wait wait let
me grab dad all right dad say goodbye say goodbye all right
dad bye oh wait also this wait let's see my bye everyone bye